Three,
two,
one boom.
And we are live with El Guapo is he tries to uh,
navigate his phone with his left hand.
What did you punch her?
You write in a table at table that we're stronger than me.
Like yeah,
this size table by our city.
Go.
Why did you punch a table?
Okay,
so I was in three states in six days.
I slept four hours per night.
I just came from Chicago and this whole thing,
I had to get up at four and then I had to shoot a commercial shoot for my buddy,
actually assist them starting at 10 and this habit at 10:30 PM so I was 12 and a
half hours in and I already said,
okay,
you,
I'm not going to do it anymore because I couldn't retain information anymore.
I had some lights,
two lines to remember your day.
We're feeding me lines.
I couldn't do it anymore.
I said,
I did it.
I,
I stopped.
But then I said,
yeah,
but if you can do this little there,
okay,
I'll try that one more time.
And of course it did it work.
And I said,
you know what,
I show on my phone,
my gloves and somehow this is how stupid you are.
You throw off your globe and two seconds after I took it off,
I hit the table.
Somehow I still needed to hit something and I decided to do it without a glove
instead of who going to love a solid thing,
guess what's going to lose my pinky knuckle and they end cap acetate your entire
arm for that?
Pretty much.
I think just for a pinky knuckle they call it a boxing fresher.
This these,
yeah.
These two are like,
that's what the old school bringing us back to karate combat old school karate
days.
I would always recommend that he punched like this.
You know what I did and and I know and I was going to do that,
but the amount of force that was using at this moment I really fascinating
milliseconds and you had to go and say it's better to spread out the impact.
You have a more because I was,
cause you're hitting it so hard.
Yeah,
I knew I was going to break the big one too.
If I would do it.
Yeah.
It was just one of those marbles and five seconds because I hit boom.
They look at me,
everybody's freaking out.
Then I go,
it's over.
It's just,
you don't pay it.
I said,
no problem,
but it's broke.
He said,
how do you know?
I said,
trust me,
I can feel it.
So I was right away.
It was call them again.
Everything was good.
Nobody died.
I know that right.
Arm's been through how it been and,
and you know this for me to lose cool like that,
that happens once every five years or so.
But I get angry.
I never get angry.
I don't have that.
Not that kind of anger that I hit something.
I mean,
how old am I?
Right.
You seem to always be a happy guy.
That's what I am.
But I,
I think there's also because I'm happy.
So when it gets angry,
that's what the fights,
that's what always happens.
I'm nice.
Nice,
nice,
nice.
Tried to diffuse it.
Then I realize,
wait a minute,
and then I'm asking them.
I say,
you're not,
you don't think I'm afraid.
Right?
I said,
I'm doing this for you.
I'm protecting you right now.
That's why I don't want to fight.
And at the moment you say that,
you know,
some of them call your bluff and then because he did it for such a long time.
Yeah.
Then I'll make sure we match spa smash.
But those are the old boss,
Dave [inaudible] busters.
No more more normal boss like this.
I,
I like
that actually.
And I,
uh,
I don't think it's a healthy buzz either.
How was your arm doing in terms of like the atrophies it growing back?
It's still growing back then.
Yeah,
it gets a little bit bigger.
No,
I have it as new stuff that I'm trying.
I have it at home.
I need bacteriostatic water for it.
It's a peptide called BPC one 57.
Did you ever hear that Ben Greenfield told me about that.
It's great for tendons and ligaments and stuff.
Yeah.
Even nerves and regrown apparently everything in red.
I mean,
we grow tendons,
everything and I'm going to try it.
I'm going to try locally here on the BICEP.
See what it does as soon as they have the water.
So it seems like the muscles are growing back though.
Like slowly but surely.
Right.
But his six years,
six years it this,
it's,
I go 25 pounds.
I can do eight times now.
Bicep curls with the right.
That's a lot better than it used to be though.
I couldn't do Firefox.
Wow.
Yeah.
Not once.
Pat Military has the same thing.
Same thing from his neck.
You know,
you want to hear it.
How crazy Pat's injury was.
Pat's disc had deteriorated so badly that his discs fused themselves and he did
it and he didn't realize that that guy's a complete animal.
He didn't even realize it.
His dis fused themselves.
He went to the doctor and they're like,
well,
we don't have to fuse it or refused itself.
Well you can if you talked to him and he looks at you,
it's like he hasn't fused neck.
Right.
He's always just like Batman.
You can't move.
So I guess grappling,
man,
I know they'll blame it on,
on punching and kicking butt.
All the knees injury,
everything.
My Rib that was out,
my loss,
that's all wrestling,
grappling.
The rest of them playing wrestlers are all fucked up.
We were talking about Kurt Angle yesterday was an Olympic gold medalist.
Fantastic wrestler.
I mean he's got a neck that literally is like the size of my waist,
but it's his neck so fucked up.
Both of his arms are tiny and you could see the atrophy in his arms.
His,
his arms don't match his neck.
And you can tell like,
I mean obviously you know better than anybody about neck injuries.
Guys always like their arm shrink because they get atrophy.
It cuts off the nerves.
Kale magic show.
But with him as both ways then.
Yeah,
well it looks,
we should pull up that picture again Jamie.
See if you can find it.
This is Ronda Rousey's a Instagram.
You,
you could see it.
I saw him at the,
at the induction and the International Sports Hall of Famers,
therefore,
but Rhonda was there as well,
and he was sitting,
first of all,
but I,
he was wearing a suit.
Of course,
I couldn't tell him while he still looks like a tank,
but his fucking neck is ridiculous.
It's so big.
But like,
look at this,
uh,
what happened?
That's us.
That's great.
Yeah.
So you look at his arms.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So the size of his neck,
his neck,
it looks like his arms should be as big as his fucking legs.
Yeah.
He just is.
I mean,
the guy's been through hell,
but look at the fucking size of his neck.
Have you seen a neck?
Like that shit's crazy.
That might build a lot of muscle around it,
I guess.
Well,
yeah,
it's all fucked up.
And it's been fused and as yours,
right?
Yeah,
for this fusion front and back while one splint,
you know,
and it opens it up.
And then the other ones are fusions.
And I've,
I have a friend of mine who has five and he can't move.
Like,
I look with me,
I have mobility because he can,
he can do this again.
Look to the side a little bit.
I was talking to a buddy of mine about a mutual friend of ours and I didn't
realize that he had done this,
but he had went to Germany and got his whole back fused.
His whole back is completely rock solid fuse still,
you know as that too.
I would at for him in the hospital don't fry.
Don Frye has that 10 disc fusion.
This Guy Ted died twice on the operating table.
He getting infections.
The watts were broke.
Everything men,
I was in his hospital,
he had,
he lost a lot of weight.
He had a big beard and he said,
check this out.
He stood up and from his butt crack all the way to above his shoulder blades.
One big zipper.
Oh Dan,
this confusion that isn't so how many did it turn your back?
Probably that.
I don't know.
I have no clue.
We've got to Google that.
That's fucking crazy.
How many do you think are in there,
Jamie?
I 13 ago,
1516.
So there's one disc hanging in there too.
He's just,
Jesus take me one one disk,
it's going to go,
they say with fusions,
if you have a fusion than the disc below or above,
I'm going to be next.
They say because my husband is 33.
Oh well it's not,
it's not that bad.
Then only 10.
Eddie Bravo has an artificial disc.
They put artificial disc and now these are [inaudible].
I couldn't do that at the time.
It was in the early,
but Eddie's got no problem with it at all.
It moves great.
But that's what I mean for me.
I can't do it anymore.
Maybe future,
you know with the printing that they do not have the three d printing.
Maybe they can make an exact copy of my spine and then they can still do it in
there.
Oof.
It will be something.
But that's a scary,
cut your spine out and put a fucking titanium one in my,
my uh,
my daughter,
my oldest daughter,
just me and my ex wife,
she's going to have to do it a little lower back.
She's got like two or three fusions they're going to need to do,
but she's going to do disc replacement as well.
Yeah.
Disc replacement is legit now.
You know what?
Braulio a steamer,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Black Belt and very uh,
famous Jujitsu guy.
He's got one in his neck.
He was the first guy that ever heard about it.
He fucked his neck up really bad and then won the worlds with a fucked up neck.
And then right after the world's went and got it,
a operated on because he was from Brazil.
They just do Brazil did it in Europe because he lives in,
he lives in England.
Do you ever need will be a [inaudible]?
I would let to,
German was look at my leg.
They were really good at different events.
Yeah.
Well you know we got really fucked up with,
um,
during the Bush administration they put a ban on all stem cell research.
You know,
they kind of like halted the brakes on funding stem cell research,
which is really a shame because now we're realizing stem cause they were,
they used to think that stem cells had to do with babies,
like fetuses.
They were thinking people were going to get abortions just so they could use the
stem cells.
But now they realize that Mesenchymal stem cells and adult skimp stem cells are
some of the best.
And one of the things they're doing in American now is sucking fat out of
people,
taking liposuction and then using the stem cells from your own body to,
to proliferate injured areas.
I did it two weeks ago for my niece digital.
But yeah,
I have no fed though.
So it had to take it out of my hip bone in order to drill a hole in their eye.
They take the marrow,
the bone marrow,
and it's unfortunate because in the fet apparently have five times more the
amount of stem cells then you have in the bone marrow.
So people out there that are fat pumped to hear that.
They're like,
yeah,
worries.
And
if I were going to injure it,
I'll go to a store of medicine.
That's why that gap,
it never got injured.
Even if he did,
he wouldn't know.
What does that guy doing these days?
I have no clue.
I know he wrote a book.
It was the last time we handle on the inside of the way.
Oh,
you guys had them on.
I mean that's five years ago.
That guy,
that guy was a fucking character.
I mean if it wasn't for guys like tank Abbott,
I mean there would have been no early days,
you know?
I mean you needed a guy look that identify with him.
So a lot of these grades you guys out there so you can do what?
I can do this.
That's what you need.
Yeah.
I had a giant bell and he would knock people dead.
He was like a Roy Nelson only with no stamina.
Yeah.
Well and and and no black belt.
No black belt in Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Well Roy Nelson is a fucking complete anomaly,
right?
Yeah.
He is like,
if you lose weight,
how is it possible that he trains so hard?
I've seen this guy throw where I would like 130 155 pounds kettlebells,
like one arm swings,
waking women being like,
it's nothing.
You would lose weight,
right?
You would think,
but he would be a 185 pound phenom.
Instead,
he's a heavyweight.
He's like a big contender and maybe it's an implant and the belly that he just
wants to do that because the Buddha belly implies kick them and he doesn't even
feel it.
He's wearing a chest pad.
He imagined someone did that.
I mean,
if girls get fake boobs,
let's think about this cause girls do get fake boobs and they fight.
Yeah.
You know,
girls have,
God,
I want to mention any names,
but we seen it.
Girls have had no boobs and all of a sudden they had boobs.
You can get fake boobs and still fight,
but what about a fake belly?
What about a guy who says,
I just like,
oh,
I like a belly.
I like looking good.
You know,
if,
if a guy had a fake belly,
I was going to try it to see if we're going to hit it to the back.
I said,
I'll make a hunchback out of him.
See if she can move the battle all the way to the back hook to the back,
lower back.
We never had one like that,
you know,
I mean the hunchback from Notradame,
that's a high right.
But no,
you'd have a show,
a hunch beck from the bottom right,
like lower back.
We can make that like a lumbar pad
work as a lumberjack.
Sleeps all night.
Then he works all day.
Like if,
if you look at Roy Nelson,
he's like the size of a really good Middle Wade.
Yeah,
no,
he is.
Yeah.
But meanwhile the guy knocked out,
Chuck Congo knocked out.
Brendan Shab knocked out some big fucking heavyweights.
Knocked out Mitrione I mean fucking knocked out.
A lot of people stayed for the over,
right.
They'll show did he knock out seven?
I do not remember that fight.
Wow.
Um,
and it was the worst thing is it's with his right hand.
So you were thinking that people going to the hill to the left up.
Yeah,
but somehow it connects anyway.
It's like Rhonda with the arm bars.
You know what's going to happen.
We can stop it.
No,
almost knocked down over him.
Remember that?
Yeah.
He heard over him.
Yup.
Stephan's true.
Jesus Christ.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
Roy is like six feet tall.
Stephan's true.
Seven feet tall.
I mean fucking animal.
Roy is an animal.
And I honestly,
I mean look at his gut right there.
How much does that,
it weighs about two 50.
Right?
He's,
he,
I'm not bullshitting.
Yep.
There he goes.
He is 50 pounds overweight and he's a world class athlete.
I mean,
you cannot say that Roy Nelson is on a world class fighter.
He says,
no way.
A world class fighter and he's 50 pounds overweight.
So you dropped down 50 pounds.
Now you're 200 pounds,
you make 85.
You cut weight.
Everybody does that.
Cut 15 pounds.
You're 85.
You're world champion.
You know,
there's nothing I butter bean.
we were somewhere,
uh,
and the athletic commissioner told me from all the boxers on the cart,
he had the best blood pressure and cholesterol.
Why?
Fuck for real?
He said we weren't a shock that the guy is into phenomenal shape.
That what he told us.
Yeah.
That's insane.
Butter bean made him look like y'all.
You're Rodriguez.
Look at him.
Jesus Christ.
I actually,
it looks good.
There is a whole family.
He looks good.
Look exactly like that.
I hear go upper right hand corner.
Yeah.
That's what he looks like when he was at its worse.
Meanwhile he's another guy knocked dude's dead man.
He is so funny.
It's such a good time with him.
And there was a percent Prince George and Kennedy,
he was there.
He's a player.
That's hilarious.
Very funny guy.
That's funny.
You know.
Um,
he's a fucking hell of a cook apparently
you can't tell,
but it like,
it was watched a video of butter being cooked some ribs and I was like,
damn,
that looks legit.
Like a smoker.
Who was cooking them in a smoker?
He broke the rule though.
Don't get high if your own supply.
So tell me about this karate combat thing you're doing.
We've seen the videos of it.
Like I liked the,
the fighting surface pit and did you watch it?
I mean that what they do with the colors,
you know when it's fighting it's like a little reddish and towards dark purple
windows a break,
you're going to run up that hill out of the pitch and us a little bit.
But I,
I like it a lot to yeah because you can use the
wall as well than the 45 angle degree there to jump up.
Like parish.
We'll do,
you know,
you can use it to put yourself a two to improve in the fight.
So I think it's really great.
I think the rules as well,
they keep kept everything on distance,
long shots,
long punches,
the hooks she had her,
the more she took his,
you know,
which are pregnant.
So they allow hooks.
They wanted to stay away from upper cuts,
elbows and knees just before the cutting a and they don't want to make a bloody,
so they understand that,
you know,
you showed him everything.
His technique of course,
but for people who have been complaining,
I'd make sure I martial arts,
I can't understand the ground and some other arts out there too complicated.
Well,
this has been around for such a long time.
Every invited knows karate.
If you find out how many people did karate,
I mean when they grew up,
look at this.
It's a beautiful picture.
The way it's filmed as well.
If you the camera,
there's one camera that goes behind the people.
It's almost like a movie.
The one camera angle they had from above.
I say,
okay,
we've got to stop with that one.
That was the only one,
but they did.
They stopped at that.
They to the heads up display.
That is also something that nobody had ever before.
That environment is perfect.
It's I just like a movie now.
That's how it should be.
That's how MMA should be fought.
It should be fun and open space.
I feel like the cage is too much of a tool that you could use the cage,
you penny guy to the cage and you could beat him up in the client's like Randy
coture rose used to do.
You could use the cage and get back up if somebody takes you down,
if you get taken down in this,
you get taken down like that's it.
You know you're going to have to get up at skill,
like real skill to see if he can get up.
You know when thinking about this as if you were in the distance,
if it was quite a distance away it seems like,
oh you could throw guys throw and then once they hit the ground,
she can't clinch,
but the person on top,
we just through,
you can rain down strikes for five seconds from a squatter position so you can't
go down there and are already saw fights getting finished like that.
So it's a very effective technique.
Why only five seconds?
Because then I go back on their feet.
They just want to keep everything short and the more attractive for the
audience,
the better it is.
It's like for instance now the knees are not in,
but you know,
we were already talking about knees to the body.
That could maybe be a really good thing,
especially because they guns out there,
so now you can use it against the take down.
Is that a Bitcoin logo?
Yes.
Bitcoin is one of their sponsors.
Really?
Yup.
Big Coin blowing up.
Now can they leg kick a leg below the knee and I've been talking to them also.
This is the good thing about this organization.
That's why I really enjoyed working with them is that they're open to
suggestions.
You know,
they're open to to rule changes.
We're going to just see what happens right now and if the urge comes up they
say,
yeah,
we should add locates,
extend.
We're going to start adding location above the knee as well.
Right now they do it below the knee,
just like to do it in the UFC as well.
Well the UFC has,
yeah,
he has everything.
But I mean we see it a lot in the UFC happening and those low because actually
they break the bones.
Right?
The formula that will,
that will snap.
And uh,
with a low kick there won't happen and we'll just jam.
You're lacking.
Yeah.
We'll also,
you can't condition the lower leg,
the same weekend condition.
The upper leg,
your upper leg gets used to taking a beating and some guys can just take low
kicks.
Yeah.
But not that low calf Kik is debilitating.
It's annoying.
And especially if you do it just after like a front kick,
somebody gives you a front kick,
you tap into the site,
immediately kick it.
So when the muscle is still relaxed,
it'll go straight through.
Yeah.
That's,
that's when something breaks.
If you can't flex.
Yeah.
We've seen over the last few years,
that's a devastating technique.
Now what are they wearing?
Shin Pads?
No,
no Shin Pads.
Only this tiny gloves you haven't there in the bachelor.
You can check them out.
Uh,
with the locates,
the storage,
which has all been knocked out by strikes.
I liked to take downs as well.
That head up headsup display.
It's really cool.
Right now is the first one.
Who ever does that.
It's a biometric nutrition training.
You know,
it's a DNA based,
a heads up display that you can see while the fighters are busy.
You get a heart rate,
respiratory,
what they eat,
what they trained before.
It's all going to start happening in two weeks.
It's will become full circle and then their heads,
what is the display will work like when does that work that's going on.
They were these little tiny things so he can see how fast they hit and what
direction they had propelling.
You could probably won't see everything.
It's amazing and these gloves are awesome.
I mean to feel great.
They do feel great.
Yep.
Yeah.
There's a lot of padding.
Yup.
That's pretty padded.
It's much more than a UFC glove,
huh?
It is,
but it's,
you know what else too?
It seems like it gives you a curve to your hand,
which is great.
Which is an issue with the UFC is the constant poking.
Like if you want to poke some of the hour with this,
you've got to kind of,
it's like the pride gloves,
right?
Yeah.
The pride gloves,
you'd have that curve to them and we saw much less I pokes and pride then we do
in the UFC,
you know?
But I never got that.
Anyway.
In pancreas we just open and strikes and ever poked anybody in the head.
Right.
So sometimes you have to think,
is this on purpose or not?
I mean,
sure,
some of it's on purpose.
Right?
It's a hard to differentiate how much of his on purpose it really is.
You know,
I should have a Jon Jones at the time he got back,
but he is so calm,
so relaxed,
show everything and then I go and I,
that almost has to be then.
Yeah.
I know you've said that before and I should have warned that thing.
Right?
That's what you were going to say.
You broke my hand.
You gotta Punch.
You can punch something pretty hard with this.
Yeah.
I mean this is,
these are great paths.
Yeah,
man.
This is almost like a boxing glove.
It's like a small amount of boxing glove.
It's like it doesn't cover the whole area,
but this is,
this is the same kind of pad as a sheet.
The psycho to the,
the,
the tricky,
you know Moishy Chucky there's still,
and you hit that off officially with the site.
Marois she Chucky and his house and uh,
took his appalling show.
It comes from the side.
It's a roundhouse punch.
It's a long hook that you say that,
but then I'm like,
this is Margo rich hand clothes.
Yeah.
Clothes I rich hand punching with the knuckles.
You're hitting with this part of your hand out of the hands.
Like by the thumb bond.
Yeah,
but today with to post your shit up.
I know,
but that's why you know they keep it long and it makes sure that you see that
technique.
Once you start doing short hoax,
that is going to be a different story.
We're going to have very close.
You're going to have knees that people go to be confused again.
They want,
you can't throw hooks,
you can throw hoops,
log hooks.
What does that mean?
Like you're just too close.
You can't throw a short hook.
No,
not for the clothes distant,
but that,
think about this.
Now you're close distance unf to remove yourself away.
It's like a combination.
I always tell my students,
write up a god writes straight or right up,
got the right straight to the body.
If I give a write up a god,
I'm too close for the right straight.
But that,
look,
I stepped backwards,
but my right and I right away I created this why limit punches?
That seems silly because they want to keep it as close to karate as possible and
as clean as possible.
Get it,
but oh,
left hook.
Like a tight hook of a guy's right there.
Yeah.
But then they say you could also throw a left elbow,
you know?
And they took that out as well.
Yeah.
So I think this is one of these things that you simply going to have to get used
to.
And think about where the fighter,
it's more difficult for a fighters,
but what do you do if a guy hits a guy with a short hook and knocks him out?
I have no clue.
Then the referee's got to step in.
Well if it's in intentionally,
of course that's a problem is going to lose.
Seems crazy.
Wow.
How can you make someone lose from a short hook?
That seems crazy when all the fights that they had,
all the fights that they had before now already.
Right.
None of it happened.
So I think we're pretty close.
I think they,
the rules meeting,
they have a guy who is repeating it like three,
four or five times in a row as I do that do that.
Plus these guys are karate petitioners.
See?
So they're not even used to it.
Yeah.
But if they're karate practitioners in 2018 then a hundred punch.
There's no,
nobody's just karate anymore.
I mean everybody knows how to throw a hooks and upper cuts and,
but I think Jay's rules are the closest rules to the 2020 Olympics is going to
happen in Tokyo as well.
Right.
Karate is going to come back in the Olympics and to 2020 yeah.
And Tokyo really shows in Tokyo and I think this is crazy.
Like,
what did this probably shorter the oldest form I would say on.
Okay.
Now it's started they're doing,
but that would be below the neck then like you could kick to the head,
but you can't punch the face.
It's going to have to really figure out dose,
but that's why I love it with it.
But the gloves,
they're probably going to be allowed to hit the face.
Right,
but not in the Olympics.
Right?
I Dunno.
I Dunno about that yet.
Yeah,
because taekwondo,
they took it out as well.
Right,
and you're going to have the head gear in boxing that you had this optional now
I brought him for and I believe,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
if it's the same glove is a make it the same way,
why would they,
what are they willing to listen to you?
Yes,
they will.
These people.
Oh No,
I'm already talking to him.
That's the greatest thing.
Keep Flash.
I'm a very popular guy.
I think that people,
it's kind of every time you get a text you get for your phone flashes,
like the light flashes.
Oh,
I do that on a,
on a bag.
Because many times I have my phone like this.
Right.
And then I,
now I can't hear it,
but I can see it now.
Big Life.
Flash flashed,
text me,
texted me,
see what happens.
I do that on purpose.
I keep my phone flat on purpose.
Like leave me the fuck alone.
I don't want,
I don't want to look at my phone five seconds because
it's flashing.
Yeah.
And Oh,
and by the way,
is she,
that's what I'm looking.
Hooks aren't penalties anymore.
Oh,
they changed it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Cause that seems silly.
Yeah.
She should be able to hook somebody.
Just,
I mean,
it's a great punch.
It's like,
I mean,
I understand.
If you want to eliminate elbows,
glory took out elbows.
You know,
Bella tour doesn't have elbows bell toward kickboxing rather.
But I think,
um,
punches,
it should be punches.
You know,
any,
any way you want to punch.
Yeah.
Well,
back fish to everything.
You can do a sliding as well.
All the kicks are allowed to get also except put the low kick to the thigh,
but for the rest,
every cake,
every jumpy kick,
everything's,
you know.
But that's,
that's again me talking and we'll go to see.
Whereas this is going to listen to you by
touch.
I wonder.
That's your eight months.
Yeah.
That was the reason.
A lot of Dutch guys one remember all the way back here with the kickboxing?
Fuck yeah,
I'm on deckers.
Rob came in,
the room came up.
God Damn Man,
he's still the old remember to have fun.
Yeah man.
Yeah,
those are the guys.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I'm looking forward to it.
If you're a nowhere on my,
uh,
what is it?
April 26th in Miami to have the first shot.
I'm pretty sure they will live out of town.
Unfortunately.
April 26 in Miami.
That's the first show in America.
Where would these other ones filmed?
Uh,
overseas.
They do,
they do it everywhere they have,
this will be the first year.
It's free guys.
So do that as well.
Also what you can do free watch or read to watch to be there or to watch?
No,
no.
Oh you go to karate.com there's a button where you can click watch it live and
you're going to be streamed,
but you also have an app and they have a really cool app because it has app,
gives you the heads up display.
You'll see there a right at the top watch life.
That's where you click,
sign the email,
read streaming to our next event.
Don't have to do anything.
Nice.
So,
um,
who's putting this together?
How do you know these people?
Well they contacted me.
It is a whole,
a bunch of guys to guide a lot of karate experts as well and they uh,
and I think their site with the 2020 Olympics,
you know,
and I've been talking about is also for a while show.
Why is not anybody doing this?
We had chuck Norris doing it right for a while.
And I thought,
I thought that was cool.
And now this,
when I saw this with a bit,
I go,
man,
this,
I truly believe it's going to take up.
I think a lot of people get to enjoy this.
Well,
I hope so.
I mean,
I've been saying for the longest time that striking sports in America,
like you got boxing and then nobody pays attention to the other shit.
I mean,
people barely paid attention to kickboxing.
Yup.
Just not nearly as popular.
It doesn't mean,
especially to me,
I'm a giant fan of Muay Thai.
I mean,
I love watching more tie and I never understood why more Thai wasn't more
successfully nine states.
I know a lion fight had,
uh,
some good traction.
They were doing pretty well,
but I don't think they're on access TV anymore.
They stopped and I,
you know,
this is the,
people are asking for it every time complaining about mixed martial arts.
A lot of people because they don't understand what's going on on the ground.
Now we finally have,
you know,
Thai boxing and,
and not watching it.
And then the glory has the back's best fighters on the planet.
Right?
I mean there's an unbelievable show,
but not enough to people watch it.
Well it's not mainstream enough in to,
in terms of like it's exposure.
I mean you get it on UFC fight pass,
which is amazing.
And then you can get it on ESPN three which is only online and sometimes ESPN
too.
But you know,
I think,
I mean you will Rico Verhoeven and you see the Jamal Benson eat shit and he said
he was going to do it like that.
And Ben said he caught him too early and density could knock them out six years
ago.
That was a fucking amazing fight.
If that was on television,
that fight was on TV and the end would,
Ricoh is porn it on and Ben's d collapsed in the ropes mean and they're big
giant fucking guys.
I mean that was an amazing fight.
Rico is incredible.
His cardio for a giant guy,
you know,
for a big
distances is ring strategy.
Everything was the complete guy.
And he's a young guy.
Super Smart also.
Is he like 29
yeah,
I think so.
Like a corner right?
Cause it started out as well.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I mean he's got a long future ahead of you.
Think of the amount of experience he has already.
How will pull up pull up Rico Verhoeven,
glory,
heavyweight champions.
He how old he is.
I think he just had a birthday,
I think.
I think he turned 29 he's a fucking beast,
man.
Yes.
Was it today?
Turns 29 half happy.
Yeah.
I just don't understand.
I really don't understand.
I don't understand why that's not more popular.
It's keeping it simple and this,
now even you take the knees out,
keep it a little bit more separate so that people can see,
see that technique better.
It's not better technique.
You can see the technique better.
Right?
I think we'll do a lot of good.
Also,
a lot of the kits when they say,
Hey Mama,
want to watch mixed martial arts when you're very young yet I don't think the
parents are going to allow that.
That's still that little,
you know,
they don't know karate.
Oh,
please go watch.
Did you see this
crazy shit?
They're talking about Conor McGregor fighting Floyd Mayweather with no shoes on
in an MMA cage with MMA gloves.
You can clinch,
but no takedowns,
no knees,
no elbows,
no kicks,
no submissions.
But clench,
clench.
You can fight him to clinch.
Yeah,
well I,
you know,
may,
whereas it's an animal that are all so,
yeah,
but still,
come on,
let me kick one kick be league,
kick,
kick.
It would end it.
If he had kicks,
that would be the difference.
But,
but Connor even fighting from the clinch,
you could tie him up.
You could tie them up and hold onto them and hit them like Randy couture style.
You remember when,
um,
Shane Carwyn fought Frank Mir and tied him up and just obliterated him with
uppercuts,
jet Bobo,
Bobo Monster.
But then again,
he chooses to stand there.
I don't think that maybe what is going to choose to stand there if he didn't
have a choice pops out.
He needs to.
Why not?
It's not like he pulls him to the,
it gets needed into face.
You see what I mean?
Because he's not clean
each with him.
If he can clinch with them and they're standing on the outside and Connor can
grab a hold of them,
how's May,
where they're going to shake him off.
He's not going to,
like,
if Connor decides to just wrap a hold of one of his arms,
just get them in an over hook and just start punching him in the face.
W Floyd's fucked his whole thing is boxing.
His whole thing is boxing.
A little buddies,
his shoulder rolls moves.
He's not gonna be able to stop Conda from grabbing them.
Connor's a bigger,
stronger guy.
If he grabs Floyd by the back of the neck and holds them in place and punches
him in the face Floyd's fucked.
I don't think he understands when you say the clinches.
Okay.
If you could strike from the clinch,
he's fucked.
I'll put my money on Connor all day if he can strike from the clinch.
Now if they just have MMA fight with boxing gloves or a boxing fight with MMA
gloves rather,
that is a different thing.
That's a different animal and I think Floyd's just so much better than,
that's what I thought that you meant.
No,
no,
no.
I mean clinching the f the what?
What I read the only difference.
They're not going to let him kick.
They're not gonna let him punch.
Not because I'm an elbow or a knee or take down or submissions,
but they'll let him clinch and punch from the clinch.
Just that alone.
Yup.
That's a game changer.
Just out alone.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
I'm going to have to see that because you know flood's going to know they're
going to work on that as well,
is going to work on those defense.
He's an incredible athlete.
I mean to Zuni,
a few things.
This is not like he's going to have to learn the whole game.
Yeah.
But holding onto someone and punching them is such a different,
it's just a completely different chapters.
Yeah.
But as soon as you hold onto somebody at me and she didn't get past the dated
your own arm as well,
you don't have the defense there as well.
So maybe we can start attacking,
taking Emma also.
That's a one hand fight it,
it's literally a ice hockey.
Right?
If you think about the graph,
but it's not hitting each other
sort of.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But smaller gloves,
Conor will have more impact with his punches.
That's true.
And he's so much used to much more used to fighting from the clinch like that
where you can hold and hit at the same time.
I'm interested in that fight.
What about foot stomps?
You know what?
That's what the last time I heard somebody say he always just super effective.
Foodstamps yeah.
Give me one fight that ever got stuck with a foot stomp.
Never.
It's annoying.
It's annoying that you ever fight where someone's foot stomped.
You know,
never know Gerry foot stomp anybody.
No,
no.
I think I'm one of those guys who would do it.
Bag it.
That's why they and why they didn't do it.
Marco,
who else was like the first guy to introduce that wasn't,
yeah.
Yeah.
You did that.
Marco foot stomping.
She got a bunch of notes here,
man.
Yeah,
I know.
I do.
I just spread it out.
This is what if my,
uh,
my pet things,
I'm throwing it out because you know,
going back to karate and with the w w with reading about it to all to get hold
of terms back.
That's,
you know,
so that's where I'm going here.
Like at the marshy gears,
we didn't know that the oil boy,
she geared to suit Toby.
I'm she hearing all those cakes you see,
but you shoot notice it.
You notice you window background.
Oh,
that's still,
you've got to Jackie's.
Yeah.
We've got to check you.
So we've got the gear I guess.
Yeah.
Um,
so how many events are they going to do a year of this?
It's all bunch.
They've got to spread them out all over the place.
I fought for the people.
What I would say.
Yeah,
just karate.com.
What a great domain name by the way as well to have that.
Yeah,
that's a,
I was thinking the same thing.
It's been expensive as fuck.
I think so too.
But they have it.
Go there for all your favorite fighters.
Check it out.
And uh,
karate Dotcom,
karate.com.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
That's a big thing to happen.
Yeah.
I like shit.
I'll give you,
who the fuck owns jujitsu.com jujitsu.com what a website that must be to own
that.
Yeah.
Well I think just because other ones out there to give you even more,
you know,
naked girls don't come.
That gives you a lot of money.
That's a lot of money.
Way More than karate.
Look,
go on sex.com oh,
that's crazy.
Don't even click on it.
You would get a bunch of popups and virus.
A friend of mine does that.
What does this Jamie makeup.com sold for $2 million rodeo.com and karate.com for
500,000 total.
Ah,
new D.
Dot.
Co for 2,000,003 weeks later.
Sold it for age,
Eh,
three weeks.
That's what he does.
Buy and donate then.
My name's Mike.
Can you go back?
You mentioned go back in time.
Oh my God.
When the ready,
all the domain names down.
Nobody even saw any of this should come and didn't.
business.com code for like 10 million bucks.
Something crazy.
He,
one of those got busy.
I wouldn't give you a nickel for that shit.
What the fuck's going to business.com?
What are you doing there?
I got to do business.
It's stupid.
If you're doing business,
you don't go looking@business.com that doesn't even make any sense.
That's a worthless fucking domain.
I bet that was a ghost town.
I bet no one's going to business.com [inaudible] dot com what is it?
No,
your business grow your pissed as fuck off.
Do it different.
Z N I s even business.
No one's going to that.
You go to that.
It's a porn site.
Can't spell.
Yeah,
you're an idiot.
You go through that as a Nigerian scammer telling you you've won them a bunch of
money and his thoughts glowing up.
Eh,
you get a telephone call.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
where did this originate?
Who uh,
what,
what country started this?
What?
Karate audio for this event.
No clue.
I'm going to meet these people face to face.
No,
no,
because I've been doing commentary and I met some people from the organization
because I did some commentary over.
So fudge together with the finished Carnavale.
She's great.
She talks to on a lot of stuff for lion fight.
I met her on her,
her boyfriend in New York,
Vic,
not,
yeah,
not this last new UFC in New York,
but in the past I got her tickets for the uh,
the UFC.
She's excellent.
Really good post fight interviews.
And she's doing commentary with you?
Yes.
Perfect.
Yup.
She's very knowledgeable.
Yeah,
no,
it was great.
Then we pulled it off right away.
So that's why we met his there.
We did it in a,
in Long Island when I was filling me.
They're nice.
And uh,
and so there was,
I'm going to shoot me man as well.
No,
no,
no.
We just did it in my hotel.
So you did commentary like watching it on screen,
is that what it was?
Queen had some people coming in with special microphone.
Shall we tuned it up?
You know,
he was exactly the same that a bunch of times for pride,
right.
Where you were in America and you were doing commentary for events that were
happening in Japan and to have a lifestyle,
we do it.
The commentary right over life.
What was that like?
It was weird.
It,
no,
it's no pain at all.
I hope that the speed was up to we know,
because if you see an buck coming,
I that I never knew.
I never rewatched it again to say,
you know what,
our Mars happening.
I say,
he said to go up and our bar,
you know,
if that delay is five seconds,
10 seconds,
yeah,
you have a problem.
But I don't think it is because they stream it out.
They shoot it out from the studio.
So it's like she watching the fights live.
That's it.
It wasn't there some that you guys did where the fights had already happened and
you knew the results.
Oh,
I did that with Steven Quadros.
We did the first 10,
I believe,
pride shows,
you know,
before 2000.
It wasn't,
uh,
sent out on paper for you.
So they asked us to do a dose shows.
Man.
I remember sitting there in Holland to a sitting with red bull.
We at stack rumor that those spills and makes you,
she's crying.
We were like heart attack pills.
We were,
it was so funny.
Quarters got so crazy.
He's so hilarious when he gets in the zone,
you know he started Sunday.
I'm watching a fight and I hear
and I looked at his side.
He's eating a green apple phone.
No,
but it's because this is eight hours in.
We're watching really boring stuff also this,
oh,
this was,
by the way,
this was not bright.
We W W we did pride,
but that we did on top of that,
we did not want to swell pride we did here.
That's what we did here in America with,
but Brotzmann and the auto show we did in Holland,
but all these old crazy Russian guys who had like an a and an Ian name and the
rest was VP Sdrm z,
you know,
I mean,
I would call him the guy with the red hair.
Oh,
the guy with the red pants because I couldn't pronounce their names.
Yeah.
There's some guys in the UFC that when I read their names at the weigh ins,
I have to pause and try to put it together.
Like some of them,
it's hard now and you don't want to butcher them and then you have these guys
like defense,
right?
They say,
Oh,
you butchered so and show his name.
I said,
what do you say,
bus route than,
yeah,
you just butchered my name.
Does as much of it.
Then it's not rude.
It's not a nest or hoost.
It's an us to host.
It's be the act.
It's not been a bird.
You know?
You see,
I mean if you really want to start Dutch,
we,
we asked the federal one time,
what is your mother call you?
He says,
Fyodor.
I said,
we don't feel though.
We did that on pride.
Everybody,
you're butchering his name as his mom calls him like that as well.
We asked,
well,
Mauro was the only one that would call him that.
Moro always called him fuel door.
If your door is of a motto is very precise with that.
Mara was excellent.
He really is.
He's great at that.
It's so nice to see him doing all those big time
boxing matches too.
Yeah.
You know,
he's a good guy.
That guy,
if you,
if you sit next to him,
it's a look when people say,
oh,
it's fake is this,
trust me.
It's half that.
That's what they say matters and talks boss.
Oh,
he gets in his own bubble and then,
you know,
if I look at him it,
that I can put my hand in front of his face.
If he's in the zone,
he doesn't see anything.
He only sees the fight and he's going to town and everybody steps away and just
looks at him now he gets,
he's going for it.
He's designed for that.
Love it.
He's doing WWE to right is insane.
He does every does WWE,
he's doing showtime boxing.
Does he do any MMA anymore?
Oh No.
Uh,
the ballot or what does he still do?
That I believe are doing a lot of the bell tours now.
So he does some of the Bella tours.
I think show the big show is problem because a lot of them,
uh,
Goldberg's doing now here,
they've got a whole crazy team.
Darren and Jimmy was over,
uh,
to Yoshi chimneys with us now.
I got him a Gig at the UFC.
We worked together first time to Saturday night.
It was great.
Yeah.
Good.
He's a good guy.
He's a great guy and he's fucking excellent.
He's an excellent commentary.
I tried to get the UFC to hire him four years ago.
So for me to be there Saturday nights sitting next to Jimmy,
I was like,
look at this man.
We're cool.
Yeah.
It was perfect too.
Cause we're friends.
It's a very easy in the commentary flowed very nice together.
You know,
we had a good time.
That's what happened.
I'll show me tomorrow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
just his friends and you can't shake,
try it out because it's just a conversation.
Right.
Well that's why me and Goldberg worked so well for so long because we're so
tight.
It's so easy,
so easy.
But whatever the UFC and him didn't see eye to eye for whatever reason,
it's a bomber.
Yeah.
But I love Anna to annex.
Great Guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Notice that.
A lot of good guys and at what the fence should know.
Is that a play by play guy doesn't need to know everything.
Doesn't need to know to techniques.
That's why we out at the experts to call or a guys.
Yeah,
because that's so many people that say,
oh,
why don't you take a a Goldberg plays?
I said,
I'm a play by play of I'm a,
I'm a comic guy.
He's a play by,
it's a completely different animal.
You our gig.
Yeah.
If especially for TV,
you got to go to commercials and do all that kind of stuff.
It's much harder to Anik and Goldberg.
Those guys are wizards.
That stuff.
That is a hard job.
It's way harder than our job.
Our job of doing color.
We see the fight,
we pitch it,
we call it,
we do it and you've been doing martial arts our whole lives.
We know what's happening,
so we see it.
We go,
oh,
that's a roundhouse kick.
Oh,
he's going to get the triangle always getting out cause he's free.
He's out.
We're watching it in real time.
They have to prepare.
I mean,
they're preparing everything like long and advance and practicing and going
over.
Okay,
turn to page seven.
You know,
beat one 52 you got introduced monster energy drink and or they're stepping into
the monster prep point.
Dreaming into EHRs the whole time you're here.
It fucking hard.
Fucking hard gig.
The coordination and the traffic cop and making sure that everything runs
smoothly.
Check Kenny Kenny Rice,
he's insane.
He does 26 professional sports like at the highest level.
I mean,
he had a football,
they never did it.
My buddy calls me and says,
but how many times did you do football?
And so what do you mean?
He says he could be the best guy I've ever heard I,
and that is the first time he's insane.
I mean these,
um,
when he came to the international fight league,
he never did mixed martial Samus but Moreau never did mixed martial arts.
But within two shows,
it's insane.
But they learn moral.
Got The DVD set.
Can we get to the DVD set?
And they,
and they actually watch it.
They start learning about it and then they get it,
you know?
So,
uh,
and they leave,
they ask you questions like,
boss,
what should he do?
Bosses,
he in trouble.
You know what's,
what's going on here?
Yep.
Yeah.
Are you still doing it for a,
it used to be world combat,
Lee?
I mean,
no.
What was the cause of fighting?
Fighting and now it's professional.
Are you still doing that?
Yes.
June.
We're going to start.
That's nice.
And so they still have,
John is John Fitch and Beltre.
Now why?
Don't know,
I feel like Fitch,
mine just went to Bella tour.
That will be not a smart move because they're going to come with a million
dollar price.
Right?
If you win this season and every way,
Claire's,
you're going to get $1 million.
Oh really?
Oh,
no kidding.
So yeah,
that's going to be a,
it was a nice little push.
I don't think the Joe,
if that's 100% still in place,
I think the jungle was tay.
I don't know.
I think,
I feel like John just went to bell tour.
See?
See if you Google John Fitch Bella tour.
I know a Benson Henderson,
Roger word.
Uh,
obviously they have Rory Mcdonald who he's in my opinion,
one of the best,
if not the best welterweight in the world.
So that's,
that's a big,
big deal for them to have him as this Douglas Lema.
I must sassy
March 1st.
They must wonder Cheddar Cheddar.
That's true.
He's got a big name,
you know,
he out there.
It is John Fitch signs at Bella Belterra.
Well,
John's 40 years old now.
Right?
How old is John?
If you had to guess,
February 24.
It's a great day to be born,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it was
40 Banda.
Yeah.
Look at me.
I know.
Shit.
I've been,
uh,
watching John Fights and she was in his twenties.
That's crazy.
Time flies,
baby.
I know.
Fuck if I go back crazy.
I um,
I had a poster of you from the first time you fought in the UFC.
They gave me one of those posts and said the world's greatest martial artists.
And it was you fighting for the UFC when you fought too.
Sheeko Soka yeah.
Remember that?
They asked me.
I said,
they messed up,
right?
That if forgot a word,
I told him specifically the world's grades looking Marsha,
but they forgot that the word.
Yeah,
they were hyping it up big time.
Yeah.
That was cool.
What a time that was Peretti.
Yeah.
He came over to Japan at the time.
I was fighting to check me out and he said they weren't you in the EOC,
so and just said something
online.
I,
someone said something about me talking shit about John Perretti,
which could not be further from the truth.
Some guy who left a comment on Twitter,
I was like,
you're out of your fucking mountain.
Never said a bad thing about that guy in my life.
I love John Perretti and I,
I used to love his commentary.
Even when people hated him when they were sitting like we were saying things
like,
ride,
I'm like a pony.
He was riding something like a pony.
Right.
He monks him like if he was great,
he called it like you saw it.
I mean,
he fucking had a,
a deep background in martial arts,
world kickboxing champion,
black belt in Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
I loved that.
And he would say whatever he wanted to say.
He doesn't care.
Yeah,
no,
no.
The fuck pull edition stuff.
Where do people get things sometimes and then it becomes like a some sort of a
weird rumor.
I didn't respond to the guy's like,
you know,
you should stop talking shit about John Perretti.
I'm like,
why?
When ever we did this,
what did I do that you remember?
The Bosch would an invitational and we did it a long time.
It goes a lot of great fives.
Nate Marquardt oh two man.
I mean Jens Pulver,
everybody was under Scotch.
I wasn't,
Colarado was in I think 99 something around that time.
There was one time he had a 16 men tournament.
You have to fight for times and it Pulver alk shitty lost indefinable to a guy
who he never heard from him.
That was weird because both our became huge.
Anyway,
Ron Waterman is fighting this out of shape out of big guy and Peretti is because
I got Peretti as the matchmaker because I knew if I have already as of the
referee,
if I haven't met as the referee,
everybody's going to come because they want to show off in front of the,
the,
the UFC match.
Trisha mentioned that j and then they're going to fight it out to an hour thing.
The boss with the invitational.
So he's fighting Ron,
the waterman a goes to Ron water when he says this,
and this guy doesn't have a little skills,
you know,
don't go to heart.
You know,
could you please don't do too crazy.
So Ron takes him down right away.
He's on top and he loads up,
had he goes,
very gentle,
starts hitting him like the gentle giant,
like really not hot.
And Peretti walks in and breaks it up and he says,
okay,
it's over.
The Big island bottoms jumps up and he gets him ready.
Phage the quarter,
jumps over robe and get him British phase.
And they said,
yeah,
like you gotta get his bull bull crap.
A little guy,
but everybody gets super aggressive and Peretti go suddenly.
Okay,
okay.
You want,
you want a fight?
Yeah.
Okay.
We reached to fight and they restocked a fight and he walks to waterman.
He says,
do anything you want to do.
Oh No.
Oh yeah.
Ron Waterman was a fucking goal.
He was a gorilla.
He takes the guy down.
He starts,
he mounts him like a pony.
He starts hitting him.
Peretti looking in the audience.
He's looking away.
When the guy gets hit,
he gets mauled Bong,
bong,
and he's looking into the audience far away and suddenly he looks back.
He goes,
Oh,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Break Rob.
Stop funding.
The guys all bashed up and he walks to the corner.
He says,
it's your fault
you did this and then you walk up.
Yeah,
they girl presidents to early days.
You could do that stuff.
Yeah,
man.
It was crazy times.
I remember when they had that one just submission only thing and they had a,
a Olympic wrestlers versus MMA fighters.
And I think Matt met met you the first one we would talk to Goldman objection.
No.
Kenny Monday.
Yeah.
And Frank shamrock fought Dan Henderson was there was that,
that was his Enovia of in that one too,
to know via,
was it,
he was an animal.
He was in world.
Uh,
was it,
uh,
extreme combat,
right.
So that was it.
That was a pretty sure,
yeah.
He was the guy who tap Mario Sperry [inaudible] already at the time already had
white glasses.
Yeah.
They look at Matt Yoga Mat Stud.
I know like Smith in his corner.
Yeah.
That was bright days,
man.
The old days.
Yeah.
Play this.
This was interesting because it,
back then these wrestlers thought that just be in,
Dan Gable was one of the guys that was doing commentary.
It was really fascinating because Dan Gable thought that if you were on the
bottom you should be losing,
you know,
they had that wrestlers mentality.
Well,
you know,
you took the guy down,
Baba booey.
That's hilarious.
That a perm,
Gary Della Bhate is the fucking Rep.
The ring card guy.
Look at that.
Kenny Monday tank.
Yeah,
Olympic wrestler and Kevin Jackson right behind him there.
Yeah.
So they,
they go at it
and he's got his knuckles up,
which is weird because they're not,
they're not boxing.
So he's like trying to wrestle him and Matt Hume Barefoot.
Kenny's weren't shoes.
They'd Matt Hume.
What a fucking martial artists.
That guy,
super smart.
We want to coach to hazing.
Could,
well you see it now and what he's done with mighty mouse,
you realize what depth of knowledge this guy has.
Not to take anything away from mighty mouse.
Of course,
he's got a tremendous amount of knowledge too,
but the fact that Matt Hume able to take this guy,
so he just drops down.
Purpose
started working.
Oh yes.
So he went for it.
That's not a good nail against the guy who knows like wearing shoes.
It's really stupid about it.
Tap,
tap,
tap.
That was a,
that was attacking the ankle and the knee.
That was both because his knee was twisted up too.
I saw John Logar and pancreas with a toehold broke his shin bone.
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
Jason de Lucia.
I just walked into the arena.
I said did,
he just broke his shin bone and he walked back and he looked at me because he's
up next.
He says,
well,
what happened to the word owl?
He said to me,
because Loeber just kept on fighting because you see the lack all flapping left
there.
Right.
And he jumps on his opponent.
He was another,
he's another forgotten guy.
Kind of an animal.
Yeah,
he was the olden days.
The olden days.
There was some fucking crazy fights when you go back then and look at those old
days.
Yeah,
I remember we,
uh,
we're talking about the [inaudible] at which Eve Edwards and these on the
podcast last week.
Oh.
And what?
We're,
uh,
w w w he was underground fighting and I remember it was a tank Abbott who was
there.
I remember that they ended up Bro.
Okay.
So this one happened,
um,
the athletic commission is there,
the police is,
they have to check.
So John Lobur goes into the cage with another guy with our jeans on and they
started wrestling.
So the letter commissioner,
the police sees that and they think that is what's going to happen tonight.
They leave,
they locked the doors,
Dj comes on,
he says,
okay,
they're gone.
We can't fight ladies and gentlemen,
like people from port industry start throwing porn DVDs and the audience was the
wildest place,
right?
So he was fighting and he's mounting this guy and he sits next to the cage and
I'm standing,
I mean I'm a foot away from him because I'm standing next to the cage and the
cases,
occasions raised and he's raining down,
straight,
straight.
And they got eaves and he,
he stops by seeing and he looks at me,
I say hooked straights dude.
And he goes,
hook straight out,
knocked them out immediately.
Not only straight,
he immediately listened,
hook straight.
Not to get out
the old days or good days though.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
well,
it's amazing to be a part of something that developed like that because there's
no other sport where you go back to 1993 and then look at it in 2018 and it's
almost unrecognizable.
You know,
martial arts,
mixed martial arts in particular.
I mean if you look at what martial arts were,
it was a lot of great Thai boxers back then.
Of course it was a lot of great kickboxers.
But the difference between the mixed martial arts from 93 to 2018 it's a totally
different world.
Completely different world in the beginning if you knew it all or you going to
win,
you know,
but there wasn't anybody who knew it all back.
Yeah.
There was a few guys that had,
you know,
a good base of knowledge in some of the other sports,
but mostly they were specialists.
They were the wrestler or karate guy.
One glove.
Yeah.
Jimmerson Jimerson
remember I,
I remember,
um,
Ken telling me about the event.
They were in the back and they thought that they were still going to be a work.
You know a lot of people and then the first fight went on and it was good though
against the sumo guy.
When he kicked his teeth,
he them into the,
into the,
into the crowd.
He said,
boss,
they got really great backstage and everything.
Buddy goes,
okay.
They thought that any moments until somebody could come in and say,
Hey,
okay,
you're going to have to lose.
You're going to have to win.
At that moment that happened,
everybody was like,
why didn't they cramp that?
I don't know.
I think there was just a couple of guys who did not like that Ninja guy that got
beat up by Pat Smith.
Remember that guy who was like a Ninjitsu Guy?
Oh yeah.
But the pressure point guy,
crazy shit.
Like in his like,
you know,
they had the preparation,
they showed other prepare
and he's like,
ah,
throwing guys out,
hitting them with all this crazy shit.
And then he got in there with Pat Smith,
fucking bad ass kickboxer and pat smashed them and they got on top of them all
five,
six elbows.
That's where the blood comes back up,
right.
Oh,
it was horrible.
It was horrible.
It was back in the day when they didn't just stop the fight.
Yeah,
but that,
that's the reason I didn't want to fight in the UFC and the first one when Ken
asked me about,
I said,
we never did it.
He said,
why?
I said,
I need a referee.
He says everybody can.
They're the guys who say,
Oh,
I brought a dye indication.
Okay,
good luck with that.
Not me,
dude.
I have a family.
I like my life very much.
I don't like to die.
I said,
as soon as there's a referee,
you could actually step in.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't like to do it.
There was a referee that was there when you tapped to stop it,
but you had tap.
But if you've got knocked out,
they just keep beating you up.
You know?
And what John said,
because when John drew,
the line was,
I believe it was for the tank,
Abbott take,
Abbott got beat up really bad.
He looked at the corner to throw the towel.
They turned his back to him.
Later on when he went to them,
they said,
well,
if we would have stopped it,
thank was going to beat us up.
That's when he told us,
so that's why we didn't throw tolerant.
That's the moment he said,
okay,
I'm going to just step in here because otherwise someone's going to die.
Yeah.
It could have easily happened in those early ones.
The early UFC to kick the first gig.
Durago dough we'll have on our lendo Veit oh,
the elbows and,
well,
not just that.
We'll all remember all on him.
Took him down,
got him in a scar fold and just elbowed him completely unconscious.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Just kept hitting them all.
It was out.
But Orlando like was one of the first real legit strikers.
Oh,
like [inaudible] fucking nasty.
Moyie Thai powerful guy and not a big guy either.
Like 180 pounds.
Halos,
scratchy,
hit some more.
So I forgot to Hippolite.
Even Hippolite and Orlando would,
I think they bought,
they fought a whole bunch of times with elbows.
Yeah.
If those guys were fighting and Hollington y'all paid.
I'll look.
I got goosebumps.
We were there,
man,
that was flying elbows.
I mean from to clean.
She would jump up in the rain down elbows to this,
to the collar bones to the delta.
I mean,
yeah.
Complete animal.
He believed too because I went back and forth.
He would win.
Then we'd woodwind and he believed would when it constantly back and forth.
So that's why it was so interesting for us.
Yeah.
If you're just getting into more tie now and you're just hearing about it the
fucking day we live in today where you could just go on youtube and find hours
and out,
you could fill the rest of your life just watching amazing fights.
Really.
You can fuck.
Yeah.
Just find out about Giorgio Petrosyan.
Just,
just Google Giorgio Petrosian you know,
who the fuck is that?
The dual fuck is that you go watch Giorgio.
The doctor babies aren't real Italian.
There's only one in our Pelion right?
Armenian though.
Wow.
Yeah,
that Italy Armenians are fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a wild race of people.
But you know,
but he is okay.
But the Italian side of him made him very
calculated technical.
Right.
Because they're meaning,
would you think,
okay,
I'm going to go in here,
I'm going to catch you.
And he was very technical as well.
It's just his mind.
But let's just record at a time like fifth 50,
four and a or something insane.
Yeah.
He got knocked down in glory.
He who's the,
he fought that African guy.
Fuck.
I'm trying to remember the homeboy he fought.
Um,
somebody,
it Longo was,
who is that?
Who knocked him out?
I forget who it was,
but Georgia was so good with angles and technique.
I mean,
his technique was flawless and if you ever watch him drill you,
you recognize why he was so good.
I mean,
he was so,
so technical and precise in his drilling,
but you see what he's doing?
He's punching him right away,
but she steps to the side is moving while he is punching,
but he lands the punches with two feet on the floor still.
And then he moved that.
That's perfect.
Perfect technique.
Yeah.
He's,
he's someone to really watch like Giorgio Petrosyan who,
who knocked him out.
So he go to his,
uh,
it was a big upset.
It was in New York and it was when glory was promoting him as you know who he
was and he just got caught.
He got caught by fucking vicious.
Stryker was not a Dutch guy,
but I think it was Daniel Ilonggo and that's his,
the Dutch guy.
Yeah.
Got Them.
Wrist.
He's a beast to you.
You can find that fight.
So you find a Andy wristy versus um,
Petrosian Giorgio Petrosyan.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
That's right.
Andy risky can crack too.
He's dangerous.
Yeah.
There it is.
Right in Madison Square Garden.
That was a big deal for them,
man.
To get in Madison Square Garden.
You know,
like to have that fight or de Vida Mayweather Darya.
Remember I heard they paid him a bunch of money to be there just to be there.
That's hilarious.
How much did you have to pay him to be there?
I had just got to be a lot.
Yeah.
And Risk [inaudible] who was a great fighter in his own,
but Rusty's a guy who really good for a couple rounds in,
knew who he would fade and he lost.
Yeah.
I forget who he lost to,
but he lost by Tko because he faded.
He faded in the last round,
but it's the fast twitch fibers.
You know,
once your explosive,
you're really good in the first few rounds and you're going to have to really
dose just uh,
make sure that you spread out.
Yeah.
All your powers.
But if your opponent is pushing it and it's forcing you to brawl,
yeah.
You're going to run out of gas.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't remember what it was that caught him.
I believe it was a punch.
Okay.
I got kicked in the nuts.
Yeah,
it was a little love tap.
Yeah.
I remember what happened here.
There's been so many good fights.
Glory.
Like I said,
I'm a giant fan and I think it's one of the most underrated,
underrated organizations in all combat sports.
And they have a great,
like a library of all,
there it is.
10 left hand boom.
Caught him.
Wow.
Crazy,
crazy.
See Joy.
Rewind that back for a second.
It didn't even look like that big of a shot.
Look at this.
Just perfect placement below like sort of a hookup or cut.
Yeah.
Like you stepped into it.
Switch to southpaw column on the left hand.
Fuck a who did it?
Well,
let me pull up Andy.
Rusty's I think,
I don't want it.
It's wasn't trying to remember who beat him.
Somebody beat him where he was winning early on in any faded as the fight went
on.
That's a Detrick tricky thing for those super explosive guys like a Conor
Mcgregor,
you know,
it is hard.
Oh,
to train our buddy.
Yeah.
I'm just throwing it out there.
Oh,
Yvonne Reus Molen beat him.
But I think von [inaudible] and beat him by decision.
Yeah,
but you see that's it.
Davi.
Kiera.
Yeah.
But also wrote small is known for his stamina.
You know,
his father was already William.
You know who he was fighting when I was fighting and he's always coming forward
that William was not the most technical guy.
Right.
But do it the guy at heart and stamina and he would come for you.
And it's very hard to fight somebody who's constantly pushing you backwards.
And that's what the he was doing as well.
With him.
100% makes them run out of guest.
You're going to kill von Reus.
Smollins an animal.
It's just like there's such,
there's such a amazing pool of talent and glory.
It was just,
it's an amazing organization to watch it.
So much talent and Wah,
Wah.
I don't know why it's not catching on because what would he sees it?
Yeah,
but k one you would think,
okay,
all these people at least going to watch watches.
What?
I would love it.
I love it.
But the average person go to fucking seven 11 and go,
hey man,
what do you think of Robin Bond was balling.
Like,
are you talking about man,
you're trying to sell something.
You go somewhere and say,
what do you,
what do you think about Conor McGregor?
Oh,
he's really good.
When he fights buses,
you know,
people will say crazy.
They know it's the UFC is
very mainstream glory right now.
It's still very fringe,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
It would have been greater for them.
Better if at the,
if the UFC had a channel,
a TV channel like the WWE do that for a while.
That will be great because then you see glory will catch on for sure.
This right.
I don't know how many people are fight pass.
Do you know that a number?
I do not know the number.
I know they're very happy.
They make a lot of money,
but I don't know the number.
You know UFC came real close back in the day to buying a channel,
but now I doubt they would do that because they spent so much money to buy the
UFC.
I don't think they could just go by,
you know,
you want to buy a TV channel.
It's hundreds of millions of dollars.
Channel One is still available.
I'd be there.
Fuck Oh really?
Channel and I don't know.
It's never ever see anything on that.
I would get channel number one.
That's the same as we're doing a new bug movie.
I would double oh one that's what I would do one instead of double o seven he's
the seventh guy below one burst.
Yeah.
I'm number one.
I'm the original.
What those,
when you go back to like,
uh,
those,
those channels,
like when people were adding,
when was the last time you heard of a new channel or the last new channels?
Like vice,
like the vice chair rail and that was like some,
didn't they buy maximum or some shit too?
I think they usually just switch.
They switched the name.
Like radio stations.
They switched formats.
Pretty much paramount.
The paramount network used to be spike TV.
Now it's paramount.
Yeah.
Well look man,
I'm just happy there's some combat sports on TV.
I'm happy the Bella tour is still around.
Like,
you know,
people would say,
Oh,
you know,
you're in competition with Bella tour.
I'm like,
I'm not in competition.
I'm not in competition with it.
I like it.
I want them to be around.
I support it.
I support all of them.
I wish there was more.
I wish it was more organizations.
It's good for everybody.
We'll fuck you allowed to get better.
Yup.
It really should.
But I really wished it was one big Moitai organization.
That's what I wish I was.
Glory was Moitai.
So use elbows and use the real full rules.
Elbows,
knees,
clench the whole deal.
Let them do everything.
Let Fight Moy Thai style.
It's the best style for standing up,
fighting,
you know,
and then put it on TV.
Otherwise you have to,
one,
you have glory,
glory,
elbow.
Right,
right.
I mean,
you have special rules like they did in Holland because Thai boxing,
they did not do with elbows.
But as special events,
like he believed in with what I was just talking about.
They edit the elbow.
Oh no shit.
They didn't use elbows.
And some of the events,
they did everything except the elbows.
You know,
that would be,
uh,
would be one fight on the cart.
Right.
They would do that.
Well,
when you see some guys fight like,
like John Wayne par or like a,
here's a perfect Nathan Corbett,
perfect example.
His whole things,
elbows.
And then he would fight in glory and they'd take the elbows away from him.
Well,
he's,
I mean he's obviously very good at all aspects of fighting,
but he's,
you know,
now he can't use one of his best weapons.
No.
Was taking the headbutts out and uh,
and uh,
you have sheer but Coleman.
Yeah.
This thing.
Remember trapping both arms.
Yeah.
Dude.
You couldn't stop it.
Yeah.
When,
when mark home was in his prime,
headbutts were a real weapon.
Yeah.
Did you head but anybody ever?
No,
no,
no.
I'll put my face in their fat.
Do you know if somebody loads up,
I'll write your,
my go with my forehead into his face.
I will keep this as close to hold tight.
I'll make sure my forehead is in front of your face and you're going to be all
my weight with it if they load up.
That's the fun part,
right?
If they did this and then at the last one,
would you just lead them so they had bought themselves in the face?
Top of your head.
That's all.
Yeah.
It works though.
We think that he will be distracted for a moment.
Oh,
for sure.
Did you watch UFC Saturday night?
No,
I did not have no time.
I was flying all over the place.
Yeah.
No,
I had to go to an a and not a show.
Not a fight show in award show.
There's this guy that fought on the undercard Zap beat Mageau Madge Sharrie.
Poff Holy Shit.
Is this,
how many times did to rehearse his name?
Many of fucked it up at the lands.
It was,
they were saying just call him Zabietska just debate and I might none
and I can get it.
Yeah.
He's,
he's fucking phenomenal.
He's one of Mark Henry's guys telling New Jersey.
Okay.
That's good.
From Dagestan.
Okay.
Yeah,
that'll where there's just something in the water over there.
Yeah.
They just train with bears.
Right.
But this guy is tall and skinny and he fought Kyle bochniac and this kid Kyle
Bochniac,
like he was shorter.
He had a hard time getting in on,
um,
and um,
uh,
[inaudible] had more skill in terms of more techniques and more things that he
could do.
But God damn bochniac he's a fucking animal.
He is a savage cause he was there at every second of this fight,
trying to win.
Never gave up,
never quit.
And end of the end of the fight,
the very end of the fight in the third and final round,
the last minute of the fight,
he's pouring it on and he's got,
it's a beat up against the cage.
He's,
he's screaming at him.
He's got fucking blood coming out of his mouth.
He's chasing after him.
This is the end of the fight was him standing in front.
Oh,
this is the,
uh,
this show in some highlights of this all highlights.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's a beat.
That guy is fucking talented.
Like you,
what is,
I think he's undefeated.
That's good.
He might have one loss maybe early in his career.
I feel like he's 15.
And no though.
I think,
see if you can find this record.
Does it say,
Oh,
this is the end.
So the end of the fight,
and I'm telling you,
Bochniac is getting his ass kicked the whole fight.
Never said,
look at this.
The end standard right in front of them.
Hands down.
Fucking 10 off.
Holloway.
The whole crowd going crazy.
This is my favorite part.
It ends.
The buzzer goes off and look fucking hugs.
Yeah,
I love that.
And they walk around the ring and I'm telling you there was not a person in the
fucking Barclay Center that was sitting down.
Everybody stood up and went crazy.
Me Too.
I was standing up.
The only time during the whole night I stood up and I was clapping.
You have to ah,
you know,
if they give it to y'all,
there's nothing cooler than that.
You know?
That's what the Holloway,
when he made that line,
you know,
he drew the line.
Yeah man.
And it became a thing.
Now 15 in one.
Oh,
how's my memory is so good?
Is that beat?
Look at,
try saying that name.
Look at shows.
Pull that name.
Okay.
Is that a bead?
The Mughal,
they shut the door shutting puff,
puff,
puff.
Michael Mitchell.
He pulls a fucking animal.
Very,
very talented.
And Mark Henry's telling me about this kid a long time ago and he was telling
me,
he's like,
he goes,
I've got a world champion.
He goes,
this guy's going to be world champion.
I was like,
wow.
And Mark Henry tells you that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean he's got the,
has a good fight coming up with,
um,
he is,
uh,
who,
who's Marlin Mariah's is fighting.
Uh Oh fuck.
Was he fighting?
I love him.
Good.
Yeah.
Craig food work,
man.
God,
goddammit.
I'm trying to remember who he's fighting.
I see his face
right in front of me.
Frank
d
go to the UFC bantamweight division.
Frankie Rivera.
Jesus Christ.
That's what he's fighting now.
I remember.
Yeah.
Who is that?
Another animal guy beat Uriah Faber.
There there is Jimmy Rivera.
Why does say Frankie Rivera?
Jimmy is an animal.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
He can head.
I'm confused.
There's too many e's.
Too many reasons.
World Jimmy Rivera who beat,
um,
he beat a bunch of good guys,
but you should have stopped at 11.
Oh one of 15 in one.
[inaudible] you're ahead.
You must fucked it up.
Yeah.
Jimmy Rivera.
Um,
he's a,
he's an interesting guy too because he's one of those tiger Sholmon guys.
Yeah,
I was just going to say,
Yep.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
when I was living in New York,
cut tied,
there was a bunch of tiger showmen karate places,
but we,
they were always like karate schools.
We thought of them as like,
you know,
like a chain.
It was linked chain,
but they developed legit MMA fighters.
It's like credit to that guy,
tiger Shulman because he really embraced MMA.
Yup.
And they really develop some real top level talent.
Well,
once you're open minded and you know that every evolution is there.
You know,
look at Bruce Lee,
the book,
the Tao of vehicle.
No,
you'll find tow holes.
He'll Luke's inverted helix knee bars.
Yeah.
I mean,
you name it.
Everything is in that freaking book.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
I remember dying a death.
He,
uh,
was a game of death are interested.
It's dragging the opening with the crucifix kind of thing that he was doing
crazy.
Right.
Yeah.
That could have escaped that.
He could have breached that.
Sure.
But it was there,
but that's like,
you know,
some pro wrestling moves.
Yeah.
You see him?
That wouldn't really work because it be flexible.
It isn't that good.
Yeah.
It was the adrenaline will make you extra flexible trusts,
then you're not going to feel the stretch.
What did you think about that crazy shit with Conor McGregor thrown the Dolly at
the buck.
You know,
I'm,
I'm giving a corner a lot of pastors and the only reason I'm giving them a lot
of passion,
it's the same as Mike Tyson.
It's like,
you know,
you're getting a lot of money.
You have the wrong people around you at all.
Everybody's a [inaudible],
you know,
if somebody says,
hey,
you know what,
we should,
we should throw something against the bus.
The whole gang is going to,
yeah,
and I just go down.
Sounds great idea.
You know,
I think he just got caught up in the moment,
you know,
be him,
tried to be him.
He can't go anywhere.
I can't pump gas.
He can do it.
Everybody recognizes he's got a lot of pressure on him.
I think he just has to figure himself out and it's going to be okay.
Deep down inside,
he's a good guy.
You don't like him and,
and away with his family and his wife and everything that he does.
I hope he never loses that because that made him love him.
Yeah.
Loves it.
Look at it this way.
Like Ray Borg was on that bus.
Oh,
I know.
He got his eyes cut.
He got corneal abrasions cause kind of through that Dolly at the bus.
And I mean who knows what's going to happen to raise eyes.
See if you can find an update on that Ray Borg condition because he was the most
one of suffered the most serious injury.
Um,
Michael [inaudible] got cut on his head and his eyes,
but I think he's okay.
I think those are just cuts and he'll be fine.
But Ray Borg that,
you know,
you get a corneal abrasion.
That's really,
that's really serious.
But what I was I say is imagine if the roles were reversed.
Magic Connor was on the bus and Ray Borg through a fucking thing here.
UFC Ray board yesterday showed a cut below his eye.
It's in his eyeball.
Oh,
Connor Mcgregor cat talking a bus.
Um,
he had a number of other MMA stars.
He and another,
a number of other MMA stars are seated on.
So yeah,
so he's got,
he's got some seriously re pour is only 24.
Damn.
You know I'm,
I'm when I was afraid of is that somebody is going to show him just like have it
with Russell Crowe.
We remember when he hit the guy with the telephone in his face,
they had to settle it for like six or $8 million because the Ottawa,
it was going to go to court and if it goes to court,
he's got a felony.
Can never fight in June in America again.
That means for Russell Crowe could have never done a movie in America again.
Show we had to settle with the guy and you had to give him that money.
That's a lot of money and guys probably balling right now.
Yeah,
it was probably right now sitting on a beach somewhere and drinking a margarita.
Go Russell Crowe.
Well it depends.
If he never had,
money's probably gone,
right?
Yeah.
Taxes.
Hello.
My fucking fantasy had a beautiful fantasy.
This guy because his feet up on the beach,
Pina Colada,
something with an umbrella in it.
Yeah.
And it's all gone now and now he's uh,
he's cleaning,
making shoe shine and then it's to make as money still in paradise because he
couldn't buy it.
Take it back.
What I was gonna say is imagine if the roles were reversed.
Imagine if it was ray Borg through the Dolly in it.
Cut Conor McGregor zone.
I'm not,
I'm not saying that it's good.
I'm not knowing that he didn't do it on purpose,
but I don't understand what you're saying.
I'm just saying,
I'm looking at not Conor McGregor.
I look at what happened to him the last two years and that's a lot to deal with.
You know,
and I think he has to sort that out.
And I think the picture of this morning with his baby and his life was there,
you could tell on his face that he don't wash something.
Like he,
he,
he was polite.
He was like a shameful,
what's the picture?
You know,
I've seen it.
I've seen him go to jail.
It's entirely possible that they might put him in jail.
Yeah.
That will be not good.
And because if it's a felony,
he's going to have a problem getting into America.
Right?
Oh yeah.
That's what I mean.
It's a very dangerous,
what do they do here for his career?
If he,
he's got to settle.
So if he settles with Michael Casser who already filed a lawsuit against him,
or we all already filed us some sort of a complaint or charges something.
Uh,
so him and Ray Borg for certain,
it's going to do the same thing.
So those two are caught.
Everybody else on the bus,
every other fighter on the bus could sue for emotional damage.
They can.
One including rose thug rose was going to pull out of the fight.
Yeah.
She was really considering pulling it out of the fight.
She was so shaken up.
You know the thing I do leg of that he at least,
because when he talked to day to day,
he didn't apologize,
but he apologized for all the people who are on board.
Right.
He said no for the fighters and so short.
So I'm happy he did that you,
it's something you can't turn back.
He,
you can
make it right or you can,
you can try to make it ride like a band aid on a wound,
but you know,
to give them all hell.
I would say give the game a little space and then hopefully he'll figure it out
and uh,
he'll sell it for those guys.
Some would say that the only way for him to really learn as to face consequences
for his actions and then if you just keep giving them space,
it's going to just keep pushing them needle and he's going to keep doing more
fucked up things like,
no,
but that will happen now.
Right?
He's to go,
he's going to have to pay,
is going to have to pay her 100% guarantee.
He wants to settle.
He doesn't want to go to court,
but he's got $100 million and he made from that fight.
Never does.
He still and what the taxes and everything off I would,
everything he's buying adult,
let's say he's got 30 million left.
Yeah.
Let's say he's got 30 million left taxes,
all that other jazz,
what you really get versus what they say you get.
It is a lot going on there,
right?
Yep.
Training expenses.
Bought a house,
bought a couple of Bentley's.
Dot.
He's going to give out a few million here.
This is going to cost them a few million minimally,
but Russell Crowe to hell thing.
Plus if they really were going to do this Floyd Mayweather thing,
they're not gonna be able to do it now.
I mean,
if he gets arrested or he is arrested,
but if he gets convicted and they wind up putting them in jail,
it's entirely lie.
I mean,
he's got charged with assault mischief,
a few other different things.
Even a felony charges that,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's entirely possible that there could be some real serious consequences
for this and if they really were going to do that,
but how many people would pay to see that Mayweather fight in the octagon?
He know,
but give us a little bit for this stupid rules.
His coach from the Mayweather fight,
it's like almost enoki when he fought Ali.
Right?
Just be four days and no more cakes above the way.
Normal kitchen above the waist.
She had no niche,
no grappling techniques.
I mean,
they shot at changing the rules just an hour or two hours before.
So.
So what would you like to see them fight if they might do it with nice knees and
elbows kill him.
I know,
but that's what I want to see.
I want to go on it with,
I mean,
even if there's no grappling,
Connor.
Oh,
tell him it's just with kicks.
Just give him kicks.
We'll take his legs out and just don't get shaven.
Just low kicks.
Yeah.
He'll take his legs out.
All you'd have to do is just fight.
Do you remember when Rick Roof has fought that tie guy and the Thai guy just
kept his hands out like this and just kick the shit out of his legs.
That's all condoms.
When you're gonna have to box him,
keep his hands out like this.
Whack,
whack,
couple of those.
And you see Floyd limping around and next thing you know the head kicks comment,
boom.
Yeah.
Okay.
But let's say the heck gigs not allowed.
Let's say they do the rules like that.
A Antonio [inaudible] first as Ali stop.
That's what I mean.
I would do,
yeah,
that will be a good one.
You know,
show he's the next two weeks.
Every time he goes to the restroom and just going to go,
oh darn it.
Two Weeks
Aldo.
I guess you were a failure.
Oh,
raises like if you have a scene,
Uriah was taking pictures when he was going into the hyperbaric chamber to try
to heal up the leg and his leg was giant purple blotch.
Like it was twice the size of his other leg.
Yeah.
Give me find it that your Ira Faber's leg after a Aldo fight.
Who was all doe?
Gonna fight.
He's fighting someone.
Oh,
Jeremy Stephens.
well you'll have to look it up.
It's like,
oh my God,
that is fucking crazy.
That is,
fuck you.
Fuck.
First of all,
you're Riaa favor is a goddamn animal.
This so Todd belief,
because it started early in the fight already.
Any Jess kept hanging in there.
Yeah,
he wouldn't give up.
He wouldn't give up.
Oh,
I mean,
it was amazing.
Amazing that he made it to the end of the round or the end of the flight fight.
Yeah.
I mean,
although it's just taking that leg out and then I remember I was interviewing
your riot after the fight.
He could barely stand up.
He could barely just talk.
He was in such pain.
But respect for that guy.
That guy is tough as shit that is painted that moment the next day.
And when Jimmy,
when Jimmy Rivera beat Uriah,
he beat him with that low leg kick.
He fucked up your eyes leg.
A lot of times that happens with guys.
They get that low leg kick and then the nerves give out their foot.
It doesn't work.
Right.
That happens to a bunch of guys.
They get hit with that low leg kick and then the nerves just stop working.
Right.
Yeah.
I think that's a more dangerous cake almost then.
Then a low kick,
you know,
because she actually can break a bone there with the cake.
Sure.
Especially if you hit the thick part of your Shin against that little cause it
the Fibula Tibia and fibia.
Yeah,
the fabulous a little tiny thing.
Yeah.
Then that's not designed for kicks.
Shitty design.
The human bones if is a shit designed your hand.
It's a shit design for a guy who punches as hard as you write and it's crazy.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
I should have,
I shouldn't have put taken off the glove.
Definitely chicken them.
Cause these gloves are fucking awesome man.
These gloves are good.
I mean the only thing about these gloves is there may be too good.
Like there's a lot of padding there that's,
that's very thick.
Like especially where the,
where the knuckles car like right here that is thick as shit.
That's like solid inch plus of padding.
Maybe even more.
Yeah.
I mean I like it as a very even cushion.
Right?
Yeah.
You don't see that a lot though.
Sometimes you just push straight through.
But this is really,
well certainly for the back of your hands and even protect your hands better
than the UFC gloves.
I think prod gloves for the best for,
for MMA or big though.
But uh,
it will cool with uh,
yeah,
they curve hence weren't open.
And even with the thumb and it didn't stop the grappling.
If you,
you're a smart guy and you're creative.
You ever thought about redesigning boxing or MMA gloves,
making something where people don't poke each other?
You just think,
yeah,
no,
I think people should just simply in a Po because why would you have your hands
open?
I mean,
you should as a fight or if it's your profession,
you should be able to not to poke somebody.
I'm like,
come on now.
What do you think about this proposition?
Because a lot of people been talking about this,
me included.
Every time you do a foul,
whether it's an eye poke or a low kick to the nuts,
you get a point taken away whether you meant to do it or not.
You grabbed the fence point taken away.
So
this way there's no warnings and you never do it because you're always worried.
Well,
you've got to get better a lot in the beginning,
but once you realize that everybody's going to get penalized.
Yeah,
you'll stop.
So it is,
you know,
it's like giving a pedophile to life.
Her sends her death penalty.
That will stop that disease for 90% as well.
Just get rid of him.
Yeah.
Um,
I think they should stop with the cage.
I think the cage is a bad environment.
I think it's too easy for guys to trap people up against the cage.
It's hard for people to see.
It's hard for the audience to see.
I don't think there's a benefit in the cage.
I think the cage was fun in the beginning because it was crazy.
Like you can't leave.
You're trapped in the cage,
but no one wants to leave.
They want to fight.
Right.
So if they're going to fight,
like that's not the best.
The best environment for fighting.
The best environment for fighting is like an open area.
The area that you know,
good,
cry,
combat has,
it's a nice area,
but it is.
See everything.
Plus,
you know,
with the holes.
I liked the voles because she can't lean against them.
You do that,
you're on your back and you're grounded opponent because they pull you back to
the ground because it karate company when you were against the wall,
you're not grounded.
But if they pull you once you were on the,
on your back,
on the ground,
you are and you can get hit.
Yeah.
You can't get away.
You can't run away.
No,
it's not like you run out into the audience.
You would have to go up that ramp,
but you're,
you're contained in the area,
but you're not trapped up against a wall like you are at the UFC with the case.
Each,
there were going to do a bit all the way in the beginning.
Right when they were talking about it with Emilia says,
wait a minute,
didn't John
didn't Frank Shamrock do that?
Frank shamrock had something,
um,
that he did shoot.
Did he call it shoot box frank shamrock shoot box?
I feel like frank shamrock did something like this where he had,
and then Bob Meyrowitz came back and did something called the up hit fighting.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
It was a crush similar,
something like that.
Yeah.
But that was in the cage to our,
David came to us to promote arm wrestling with where you could hit your
opponents.
That's right.
Your arms are tied up and due to a wail on each other.
Oh my God.
That was the most ridiculous shit ever.
I forgot about that one.
I forgot about that.
One guys had their arms taped up taste together and then they were punching each
other in the head.
What the fuck was that called?
Extreme arm wrestling or something.
I mean,
any name is good for that because that shit was so stupid.
It didn't.
A couple of MMA fighters get involved in that too.
I,
I'm pretty sure you know,
if there were not on the lists of,
what is this?
What does it call?
Here we go.
Yeah.
They tape each other.
Ex ex arm.
Extremely extreme.
He's got a glove to,
oh my God,
but as soon as you let go of that thing that you're holding in order,
then you don't have that balance.
You have to,
if you're right handed,
you're going to to put you your there.
Oh my God,
this is so stupid.
This is sold.
They simply pushing down and when the fight like that,
right.
This is so fucking stupid.
This isn't,
this is a fight with the bartender tied up like that.
The bartenders behind the Bar,
your arm is somehow tied.
You're going to have to fight.
This is so stupid.
I want to see some of this x arm.
That's it.
It was called a new sport is born and not really.
He showed it.
Yeah,
I'm getting crazy.
I'm throwing kicking incredible athletes.
Yeah.
Ready?
Go.
I'm gonna Punch you in your fucking head.
What?
How do you,
when do you win by take bar.
Oh my God.
My bar on the table.
That shit's ridiculous.
That it's so ridiculous.
Wait a minute.
He's onto something.
This is so stupid.
Oh my God.
Oh.
They stopped it.
But meanwhile the tied up pin his arm.
You pinned his arm.
You win.
Wait a minute.
This is so fucking stupid.
Why don't they just been him right away so you don't get hit.
Look at this.
Doom.
She imagined if you pulled out your fucking arm.
This tool used to be a filling you up few,
but they fucked you over.
We fuck you.
I don't look at anymore.
You bull that safety glasses.
The Ref has like you should just in case blood come stick rate in these sites.
Spit and shit.
That's a camera.
Oh my God.
It's so dumb.
That is so they get so fucking dumb.
Oh my God,
I forgot about this.
I'm so glad you brought this up.
All that guy got kicked out and he's hanging on to day.
I got him.
He's out cold.
Untied me from this dead man.
I did it to a trading partner.
Fucking stupid.
What'd you do to training partner?
I was very angry
and a more angry than you were at the desk.
You know what?
He had a fight and two weeks and he said this week at my friend's going to go to
Vegas for a Bachelor party.
You think I should go?
And I go,
you're asking me for advice?
Yeah.
I said,
no,
don't go.
This is going to go wrong.
You do drugs.
You got drunk.
Give them everything.
Of course it went wrong.
He did go.
So now I'm angry because he had a fight going on and I,
uh,
I said he wanted to train on,
he was back on Saturday or Sunday and went to [inaudible],
let's do Monday,
give you an extra day rest.
When I came in and this time you're normally,
I never went to knock somebody out,
but I want to knock him out just because you couldn't find anyway already with
the young angry boss and every bus,
no,
he didn't listen.
And now you got to fight it as your comp constantly complaining about you're
losing.
He had,
I mean,
it has a reason and this was one of the reasons this was the moment for him to
get a lesson.
So I think first punch out through incredible heart and I remember I hit him and
I almost didn't feel the impact.
So you know that I hit him with a loose,
make sure to say what straight through.
And I remember him falling over the rope
and I grabbed my stuff and I walked to my car,
my car,
it was in the garage who were in the garage and the ring was in there.
It was at the front of my place and I walked over to my car and while I walked
over,
I look back and it was still hanging.
It was no movement whatsoever.
I got no,
I got,
I got started to get worried because now it was out already funded two minutes
and no movement whatsoever.
So I get in my car and then I drive by it and he still does no more just
somebody taking care of him.
And I got out of the car because I wanted to take care of him.
And as soon as I started walking,
I started,
he started twitching.
So I got in my car and I drove off.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
Yeah.
But it was a long time to fly.
He fought and he lost.
But he was lost.
He knocked him out two weeks ago.
No,
no,
no.
He was losing already.
And it was every time it was somebody else's thing and say,
well maybe you should stop smoking weed for a while.
Maybe that was going to help them.
We know.
What about that?
Maybe that would help.
No.
So if you,
if you wake up in the morning and he'd smoke a bong and do that all day long and
you keep doing it,
I mean maybe that's,
that's the reason,
right?
You're not getting really up to your potential.
It could be a fabulous you nick the is.
Yeah,
it does affect him.
There's always a exemptions.
Yeah.
He's a real exemption.
I mean,
when people,
when people think about potheads,
you think about someone who's lazy and you think about people that have bad
endurance,
you would think he'd be lazy.
But Nick Diaz has phenomenal insurance.
I mean,
he does triathlons.
Do you know he swam from Alcatraz five times?
I said two times and he corrected me.
He goes,
no brow five times.
I'm like five.
I swam back from Alcatraz five fucking times in the shark infested waters.
But there were also,
they said it was a lot of,
you know,
it was not as bad as what they let to prisoners.
No,
of course it was all my blood just because athletes are just so much better now.
But if you didn't swim,
it's not like they let them prepare.
And prison,
like do laps in the pool?
Like those guys,
they didn't have any endurance.
No,
they didn't have a little pool either.
Right.
I'm thinking how can you walk,
can your practice with me?
But it's a hard one.
That's a hard one.
I'm sure some of the made it.
There's a couple of guys did attempt to swim back from Alcatraz and one guy,
they found his clothes on the beach and they never found him.
And they assume that he got eaten by a shark or some shit and drown and they
just found it's close.
But it's entirely possible that guys swam all the way.
If he was a fucking real animal,
could swam all the way,
took his clothes off and when fuck you,
I'm out of here.
Back then they didn't have no database laughing.
Right now he's nine years old.
You got a call in number?
I got free.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think nobody,
uh,
I don't think they know of anybody who definitely successfully made it.
But today people do it all the time.
It's a like all those triathlete,
endurance athlete,
those a serious animals,
those guys who do like triathlons,
ultra marathons,
those mother fuckers,
they have ridiculous cardio like show like a 90 year old woman who did it.
Really?
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
yes sir.
I'm also from Alcatraz.
You have go to Elko tests.
You did right when I was,
it's cool.
It's pretty cool to go to Al Capone's sal and just to see all that stuff.
It's weird.
The movie The rock.
You remember that?
That's right.
Clint Eastwood,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
from Alcatraz,
which one's the rock?
The Rock Nic cage.
Nicolas Cage.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the difference.
That's right.
Escape from Alcatraz.
The Hopkins.
Yeah.
Those guys.
They ski.
No,
no.
What's his name?
[inaudible] plate.
I'm a James Bond Board church bulletin.
Chaga mushroom [inaudible].
Sean Connery.
Sean Connery is also such a bad ass guy.
I always love Sean Connery.
My favorite interview is him with Barbara Walters.
We,
he's talking about smack and women.
Oh,
I was just going to say that
sometimes you don't listen.
You let them have the last word and national enough and they need more and more.
You should just take her around and yeah,
there it is.
Escape from Alcatraz.
Clint motherfucking Eastwood.
It says an escape.
Yeah.
So I don't think anybody like definitely escaped and made it across the ocean.
I don't think like there's one guy that they caught in San Francisco still on
the FBI's most wanted list,
but there some drowned.
There's still on the FBI's most wanted list.
And what year was it?
This gate?
62 oh wow.
They might be a lie.
It might be still alive.
Wow.
Those three guys escaped.
Yeah.
Look at those creeps and it never got found.
Wow.
It's probably drowned men.
If you hear us,
call us our tire rod day.
That will be a story.
Mother drug carved out ocean.
Google the 90 year old lady who made it.
That's insane.
You know what?
If they would still be alive,
they should write a book.
Right?
And then just before they died,
they say,
here,
this is how I escaped Alica dress.
And when he proceeds goes to the family,
wherever you
write a novel and gall,
why this is all fishy.
I,
yeah,
like Oj Simpson.
If I,
if I did,
did you see the interview where he kind of like says that he did?
I saw that.
I didn't see it.
Oh yeah.
It's tricky.
You know,
you hear him saying,
because sometimes she forgets he isn't talking to third person.
Sometimes he talks shit and then he,
he took dish.
Suddenly he,
he made this really,
we have karate stance.
Like you knew karate and that it's quiet.
He says,
oh,
of course.
Uh,
you know,
that will be in my mind.
You know,
he would correct himself every time.
Yeah.
Took a karate post.
It's weird that he's out there roaming around now ladies.
Oh,
I'm sure this is a lot of crazy bitches out there.
Apparently that Parkland shooter,
that kid that killed all those kids in Florida,
it just gets fan mail all day long.
They say,
goes with a Marian girls want to marry him.
Yeah.
That was the thing with Richard Ramirez,
the night stalker,
he just got tons of marriage requests.
There's a lot of girls who want to marry psychos.
Yeah.
It's so strange.
It's a,
yeah.
Something really bad happened to them or who were young I guess,
you know.
I mean,
otherwise,
how'd he get there?
How do you get it was to a spotlight that I don't know.
Yeah.
I people when it's wet,
we need bigger penalties for things.
That's where we need,
I like that.
What you said,
you know,
no more warning.
Boom.
Do it one time.
I think she's good at it.
Terrifies.
Yeah.
For fights.
I think I pokes,
well,
here's the thing.
Even if you didn't mean to do it,
the other guy got poked in the eye and that's a significant impact and it could
affect the vision and we know many fights that have changed,
changed the course of the fight.
Like Travis Brown,
Matt Mitrione,
Mitre owns wing.
The fight he gets,
I poked by Travis Brown and he winds up getting beaten up and stopped.
It was,
it was a big,
big moment in the fight and it came from an iPod.
Yup.
Those kinds of situations happen.
And even if they're at by accident,
it doesn't matter.
They happen.
And when they happen that's a giant impact and that giant impact should be
penalized.
Yup.
Cause that guy can't see now it's like looking like this.
I got the stabbed in my hand in pro wrestling and you literally what they say
you'll see three people.
Yeah I couldn't,
I go to folks,
referee goes by,
I get,
did I get see anything in Japan?
Yeah it was protesting.
He sucks.
Fight fighters and okay I'll fly.
But don't they do some hard pro wrestling in Japan sometimes.
Right.
Strong style they call it.
So that's why it's so good for the mixed martial artists because they use real
submission moves.
If you go to the WWE,
you know they,
you see moves.
So they tap on things that are not even move sometimes.
Right.
So you know,
it's teacher Debbie guys got mad at me cause I was analyzing the figure four
toehold and I was saying the other guys actually in a better position,
the guy who was getting the toehold has a,
he'll look right,
let's reach over and grab a hold of that shit.
You got it.
Yeah.
People were mad at me.
[inaudible] guys were so mad for telling the truth.
There was saying that I'm somehow or another diminishing their,
their thing.
Like you guys just did Wrestlemania last night.
It was the biggest fucking thing on TV that's not diminishing it,
but it's,
you get,
you can't get mad if someone's pointing out reality.
It is real.
You know what if they say,
I think they're amazing guys.
Yeah,
they're,
I mean I was almost about to sign for them a long time ago.
Uh,
but I would,
I thought it was going to get away with like 2030 shows.
No,
no,
no.
Minimum was two 2,220 shows yet that's what out to traveling.
So I go,
you know,
and these guys take bumps every single night.
Can you imagine?
And it's two 20 shows.
You know,
if you look at it as stone cold,
Steve Austin,
all these guys,
the Rock,
Dwayne Johnson,
all these guys,
they did way more year.
They did two shows in one night.
They say they were going from town to town.
That's a crazy life.
A stone cold.
Steve Austin eating a role because that no more money.
Raw potatoes eating in the car,
driving from event to event cause he had no money,
had no money at the time he was building himself up.
He was eating raw,
raw potatoes.
Yeah.
What does a raw potato tastes like?
A raw potato.
Like not good little bitter.
Right?
Remember we can share.
Mark was the world's most dangerous man.
Yeah,
he did.
It just jacked.
He was so jacked back then.
It was ridiculous.
Remember how big he got?
Holy Shit.
He got big.
Yeah.
It was like 260 pounds
yet so unbelievably tough way to make a living.
Unbelievable tough.
What does this to start just share to retire.
Yesterday she got kicked in the back of the house show and snapped her neck.
But you see how show like a non televised show.
Wow.
I'm one of the 220 shows they have to do like uh,
not in la like whenever Kansas Wednesday night.
Whoa.
Very injury prone man.
Because she's constantly,
constantly,
it's,
it's really a amazing older falls.
All these things are real so people can say whatever they want and know.
People say,
oh,
protesting is fake.
Yeah.
So it was acting.
So let's,
let's be honest there you got one of your worst injuries from stunts.
Nowhere effect lights out to show on Fx.
You Remember Miguel?
Honey,
bye bye.
If you're,
by the way you want to talk to him.
He's the lead guy in the mine hunter and that TV show.
What is mine?
Hot Mine Hunter you didn't see on Netflix.
That's that show about serial killers.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Yeah.
I mean look man,
that what they have to do is one of the hardest jobs in all show business 220
shows a year.
Getting slammed and knocked around like that.
It's one of the hardest jobs in show business.
But you're a tough guy.
Don't be such a pussy.
If someone says that a figure four leg lock doesn't work,
don't talk.
That's when the skin is very thin.
Just very thin.
I don't understand.
Instead of digging this constructive criticism,
yeah,
I've got nothing but respect for them.
Yeah,
but relax to take jokes.
You can't tell jokes anymore.
I was so on inside MMA,
right.
I,
I'm telling,
I think at the rep up and I didn't even notice was the rep,
I don't even remember I sat this so I'm busy and I said,
yeah,
right.
Who could write,
who knock out?
We shoot,
we,
she highlights.
I'd tell Kenny Rice.
I said,
mad right hook,
duck out.
I said,
I love to see that.
It's so underused.
The right hook.
I said,
you should really practice that.
And so Kenny says to me,
how do you practice that?
I said,
well,
if you're married,
you said,
hey honey,
can you come over here for a second and right away I'm looking in the camera and
I say,
I'm kidding.
Of course,
right.
I'm literally saying it because I know there's always people,
but I started laughing.
It's a joke.
I don't even remember me saying this on my Facebook.
I had this,
you know,
feminist organization that attacking me that I couldn't say that I would hit my
wife and I go,
I didn't say,
I went through the whole show and I go,
where did I say it?
And it was the literally the last 20 seconds where I said it and two seconds
later I said,
I'm just getting,
it's a joke.
You could never do that,
you know?
But people are so thin skinned can do anything.
And these were the same people when they asked me what did I enjoy the most of
women fighting,
I thought I'd make a joke.
I said,
the way it's all right.
I thought it was funny to
say because they're in the bikinis,
right?
Yup.
Say Feminist Organization,
we are in this business and you get to,
and I told him,
I said,
if you're in the MMA business,
get out.
Because we opened,
they opened like they just don't say it on the,
on the nice end.
Right on the nice end they think,
yeah,
the dark end.
Or they go like,
you know what I will do at this moment with the girl like that.
That's how you,
how bad it is.
Do you ever see Derrick Lewis is Instagram?
Oh,
Derrick Lewis has the most fucking hilarious Instagram pushing it,
pushes it as far as pushing it.
You see the shit that he did with Ronda Rousey after he knocked out Travis
Browne,
after he knocked out Travis Brown,
I mean he knocked out her boyfriend and he's got,
or now her husband and he's got all these videos of him,
his face and he's,
you know,
I'll play.
They put his face on someone else's body and Ron does face on someone else's
body.
It's like he's crazy.
He's crazy.
It's funny though.
He's how so?
There is a liking.
His Instagram page is fucking hilarious,
but I'm always like,
what?
How long is it going to take for someone to find that page and just go over his
archives to go what in the aisle like you can't do because it's obviously he's
joking around and he's a very funny guy.
Before you saw the after.
Oh,
Derek is fucking funny man.
Who he fighting next?
I don't know,
but
sting.
Ridiculous video.
So people do stupid shit.
Like if you just go to his,
his Po,
it's almost always he ever,
what's going on with his hand?
What does the gun on their,
damn,
that shit hurts.
I have a fourth metacarpal fracture.
Oh,
February 21st all right,
well he ain't fighting anybody anytime soon.
Oh,
they're digging in there.
What are they doing?
Oh,
they're extracting.
Yeah.
They're pulling out the puss.
Get in their son.
Pull that pass out,
right?
Yah.
Yeah.
They did a one to me one time I was in Japan and then Hennison stands next to me
was at the table eating and he says,
where's the heat coming from and to to me.
And then he put us with his arm and my arm was infected and it was trimming out
heat and he goes,
dude,
you could staph infection buses is really bad.
You got to lose.
I said,
I'll do it when I'm home.
He says,
no,
no.
You've got to go to the hospital.
And I know this is very bad.
I went to the hospital in Japan.
They put it in an insurance.
I just,
big giant switch.
You start pulling out stuff.
It was like the Green Goblin,
that liquid,
that green glue liquid.
Completely clear,
not one little sliver of slime or whatever in it.
Completely clear.
Like the doctor was pulling it out and he goes,
Ooh God,
you start talking to all the other doctors and they came running over to says,
I want to say they pulled it out and it was a whole big sewage filled up with
green clear stuff.
Whoa.
Weird.
Right.
Very
weird.
What they do with it.
Give you some serious antibiotics.
Antibiotics.
Yeah.
There was this moment pan with Daymond Perrier.
Remember when?
I'm sure we did that show and how much laying on the bar.
I was acting like I was drunk and everybody says do it.
Dad was unbelievable.
You were at,
that was how sick I was,
so I acted like I was drunk and I was sweating,
but I was from the real sickness.
I was literally between takes laying on the desk.
Wow.
I did.
To take and would fall back again.
Wow.
I was destroyed.
Did you fly home with that?
Yeah,
but it was two days later.
I started feeling much better than the next day after they gave me oral
antibiotics or Ivy Oral Niv in my view right away.
Yeah.
So staff,
it scares the shit out of me,
man.
You can lose something.
You were met a staff on Kevin Randleman.
You had holes the hole in his arm underneath.
Yeah,
like a snob box.
You know,
like we did the tobacco thing.
You could hide it in there.
You can literally see his muscles.
Yeah.
And all his tendons and everything in there.
It was fucking crazy.
Kevin Randleman staff.
Yeah.
He's got one of the most famous staph infections ever.
It's horrible animal.
This guy,
my friend Ari and I,
my rei was taken Jujitsu for a while.
We were playing pool and I noticed him walking around the pool table.
He's limping.
And I go,
wow,
what's going on with you man?
He goes,
ah,
figuring out a spider bite on my knee.
Look at that.
Look at a God damn.
That's crazy.
That is so crazy.
That's like systemic.
When it's that bad,
when is that deep and your body?
So I looked at Ari,
I go,
what?
you got an a spider bite or let me see your knee,
and he pulls his pants leg up and I go,
dude,
you have staph infection.
Listen to me right now.
You've got to go to the hospital.
Immediately.
He goes,
what?
It was a big deal.
I go,
no,
no.
This could kill you.
You have a real bad staph infection.
It was like a fucking big Whitehead and was like,
go to the hospital right now.
He's like,
are you serious?
I unscrewed my cue.
I'll go,
dude,
we're done.
I go,
you gotta go to the hospital.
I'll take you.
You want to go to the hospital right now?
He went to the hospital right then and there and they were like,
Holy Shit.
Oh.
Hooked him up with them.
Then he got it again.
I think afterwards,
like sometimes it can relapse when you get it bad,
when you get it in your system and you don't completely get it out of your
system.
Sometimes it can come back.
A friend of mine had this point,
blue blood poisoning and from a,
from a low kick it was all his leg.
There was fluids in his little pinky thick,
purple line started going up on his body like dough is the heart.
Oh yeah,
you got to see that leg.
I mean they went in that they stapled it close with like 34 of those staples to
hold fire.
He's got a scar.
Ah,
crazy scar.
Yeah,
from low kicks,
from locates.
That's didn't treat it man and it just kept on working and something went wrong
and [inaudible] affection.
Yes.
That's clutter.
No one has that.
You see how I did that clinic?
I see fingers.
All right that,
that's fast.
What do you think I need to ask you about some certain shit.
Like what do you think about the Jon Jones situation like with John Jones test
and positive but saying it was a tainted supplement,
which think about all that.
I think Azure.
Okay.
I'll go back all the way back window.
You could do pretty much anything you wanted.
Right?
Right.
I brought my own bread on foot everything to Japan.
If I would go to a hall,
I will bring my own water.
I wouldn't drink the water they had there.
I heard all the war stories of fighting in foreign countries that they might
taint it or something to do something.
Make sure every product that you take as a professional athlete is your
responsibility.
You know?
So once that happens,
and I thought that tainted suppling wasn't that same thing to supplement as Yoel
Romero head,
I believe it was that same thing to Rome and they have the same manager so it,
so their manager didn't say,
Hey,
wait a minute,
Joe Ramiro,
you maybe you shouldn't take this because I don't know 100% and I'm,
I'm just talking at anyway,
even if that's not the case,
as a manager you would say,
I think from now on you should buy only products that are on a list.
A don't do anything else anymore.
Just to make sure.
Because people,
you know where the smoke is fine.
That's what people think.
It's always like got 40 I was very happy with Yoel Romero when he,
when he brought a product,
I say that's the first guy who actually does that,
right?
They took the product,
got it off the market because it wasn't there and he was cleared.
I said,
okay,
finally I would've,
Tim means did the same thing.
Tim Means tested positive and then he found it also,
we found it on the shelf.
They did an independent test of it and they said,
Yep,
it's in this stuff.
That's a real common thing.
A lot of baseball players are tested positive for the exact same thing that John
tested for.
Apparently it's in a bunch of different supplements,
but you get it in trace elements are a trace amounts,
you know,
you're not getting like big amounts and a lot of it comes from,
they take the same Vat in,
you know,
China,
wherever they make that shit and they'll make some steroids and then they'll go
in and out but do a shitty job of cleaning it out and then they'll make some
creatine in there.
It's like the gluten free products,
you know,
because sometimes they use a machine that has product with gluten in there and
then it's painted.
It's like that.
Yeah,
it definitely can be.
It definitely can be.
You know,
I've heard a bunch of crazy stories.
One of the craziest one was they think that cocaine,
sometimes they cut with creatine and creatine is often infected with this
steroid that it's often tainted cause you're,
you know,
you're getting cheap creatine from China and they use creatine to cut cocaine
with,
I got a good idea.
Don't do cocaine if you're a fighter.
Wait a minute.
That's just crazy.
You're just crazy.
I didn't even make sense.
Don't do coke.
When Katie come back,
when it come back.
Joe,
I don't know.
I don't think they've done is hearing yet.
Oh Man.
What a talent.
What a waste.
He did the California hearing.
But I think that the Nevada state athletic commission and you saw a,
I think that's in April sometime.
I really hope we're gonna see him soon.
I really hope he turns his life right.
I truly,
I truly the best.
Yeah,
he's the best.
I mean the impact that he can have on on,
on kits and on everything going out as a,
if he trains for four fights,
four more years.
Yeah,
just beat everybody.
I then go out.
I think he can still do it to yank it.
You still come back and maybe you know,
hope it's clear.
One thing is clear from his test is that whatever he took was a tiny trace
amount and it must have been accidental.
Must have been.
This is according to Jeff Novitsky because if you look at right before that
test,
he tests negative,
he tests positive for the tiniest amount and then he tests negative again right
afterwards.
She is a tiny,
tiny,
so it has to be an accident and it definitely didn't have any performance
enhancing benefit.
Well the levels that he took,
they're talking about trace amounts,
but you see this is where comes in play what he did before and that's why he's
going to penalize you see,
so you're all responsible for your actions.
That's what's happening now.
And this was the first time that title two which is so crazy.
I know.
But you know,
if somebody has a chance to do it back,
what a comeback that will be.
I think he can do it.
Hey,
get 100%.
I mean,
you think about his wit,
his victory over Daniel Cormier,
the way he did it,
that left high kick and then
puts it away.
He set it up that entire fight.
He was setting it up.
But I think that when he came back and the before the last break that I said,
okay,
now we can let it fly.
I think you set them up enough.
I love that men making a pattern and then breaking the better.
And that's,
I love that style of fighting.
Yeah.
Nah Man.
I mean he's such a talent.
I mean,
and just,
but isn't it funny how some of those guys that are so talented are also so self
destructive,
so common.
It's because,
oh no,
no,
but it's not only that it's talented and because they're talented propels them
up in the limelight and suddenly they become somebody.
And it's like I said with corner,
you've got all the say.
Nobody says no to you.
Right.
And if you have that constantly,
24 seven around you,
yeah.
You start becoming,
you think you're God,
you can start doing things that other people can and you can.
That's the worst part.
Yeah.
I mean you look,
I mean he,
that he didn't go to jail.
Think about it.
What he did.
All right,
hitting the woman and an the drugs out of the car and the woman was pregnant and
she was injured.
I mean,
there's a serious thing.
A normal person would have been in jail.
Right?
So,
and with the money situation and how we changed suddenly with core me a
Wednesday where you know,
where,
where they filmed them at the interview and they kept it rolling and they didn't
know they were willing and he starts,
hey,
how much money you have?
I got so much more money.
I got this,
I got this and I go deal.
What are you doing?
What is right?
It's a weird thing to say,
but then again,
you think of it,
he's the,
he was the youngest champion also ever,
right?
I mean,
the guy is young.
I was an idiot and that I wasn't needed when I started at 28 I was still the
grown up.
I was completely crazy.
So that's why I never blame people because I know I wasn't a complete idiot.
Right.
Well,
you have a great perspective on it because of the,
yeah,
yeah.
You've been there.
You know what it's like,
and you were a fucking wild man and now you're very calm except for when new
occasionally punch the table.
Yeah.
13 hours is too long for the commercial shoots done do that.
I know what that's like though.
They keep on wanting you to do it again.
You get an angry like,
fuck.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's an ego thing too because said it's fine,
but because they said would be,
you know that now it's in my head.
I go,
I just want to do it for them,
so I don't feel as bad as I go.
Hey Man.
Right,
right.
It's just pushing it.
It's just saying no a little sooner.
That's the trick.
Do you miss inside MMA?
Yeah,
I do.
I never,
and I told this always when I had to show,
there's never been a show when we were,
uh,
that imagined.
Today was Friday.
I had to film never ever.
I thought,
I wish I could stay home tonight.
I always wanted it to go and meet who everybody was.
Whoever was there.
I love that show.
It was great.
You saw the new talent.
That's where Conor Mcgregor,
you know,
come center and it was just starting and interviewing him.
It's great.
And any shitty old guys,
you don't fry.
And Coleman,
it was great.
There was a fun show.
What happened with it?
I think just numbers.
I think it's,
you know,
nowadays with everything streaming you can,
there is no breaking news for us or it has to happen on Friday.
Should come along and reboot it and give you a show and just do it online where
anybody can get ahold of it.
Dude on youtube yet,
but then also do it every day,
but make it,
you can't compete with a very short or Gamma Ray.
We can while you can,
because that's,
that's happening now.
So you need to show a live show it like,
like a podcast,
but you need to do it in every day or when there's breaking news.
Yeah.
Well every day is,
I mean,
fuck man.
If you did it every day,
it would just take off if somebody just figured out how to do it and got you
into a studio.
Yeah,
but you know what?
We're waiting.
First of all for the Kevin can wait.
If that goes to a third season,
I'm going to have to have that.
Then I got 11 shows with the professional fighters league.
I just started karate combat,
you know,
so I'm good.
I would like to keep the free time.
What do you,
are you a regular and Kevin can wait?
Yeah,
I will.
I'm a regular on the show,
but not a regular of the show.
That would be,
if this goes to a third season,
I become the Casper that then,
then it will be there.
So you play on the show.
His neighbor,
like last year I had exist,
16 or 17 episodes.
The guy,
crazy guy,
rude girl from Holland,
you know,
and he's not the smartest guy,
not the sharpest knife in the drawer.
It's very funny it.
That's fucking great.
Yeah.
That's so cool that Kevin did that.
That's very cool.
And it happened because once inside MMA stopped,
he said,
now you can finally do an appearance on our show,
because they were filmed Friday nights in front of a live audience.
Right.
So I could never be on a show.
So I did a guest appearance.
The writer's liked it.
They got me back.
And then I did two,
three,
four shows the first season at the end.
And then he called me.
He said,
dude,
they love you.
They want you for next year.
So there's also awesome.
I sat this 21 years ago,
I believe,
against a George Gross when he interviewed me for sure.
Doc was just started Chertok 21 years ago.
And my dream job,
he asked me about,
and long story short,
my dream job will be to work in an American Sitcom.
I said,
and he said,
you don't want to fight.
I said,
no,
I did all that.
I just want to make people laugh.
Look at you there.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
It's so funny.
What a what a life that is,
man.
His Sitcom.
Everybody's happy.
Yeah.
It's such a good time.
I did that shit
for five years.
Yep.
Yeah.
It's interesting what happened with the wood they were going to reboot it.
Will was the factor fear factor.
They did reboot it with ludicrous.
Oh,
so,
oh,
so they didn't know I wasn't going to do.
Oh yeah.
You're too busy to write jokes over the place.
I don't want,
I was got into a fight.
Remember that?
Oh yeah.
Some silly guy.
Poor fuck crazy people.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a problem with a reality show because you're dealing with all these wacky
people that are trying to get famous.
Whereas you're on a sitcom.
You dealing with the other people that you're working with on a daily basis.
Like when I was on news radio,
you know,
we were like a weird little dysfunctional family.
You know?
That's what happens in those,
those sitcoms sets get very close to each other.
Yeah.
It's a lot of,
it's a,
it's a great job,
man.
It really is like the,
I'll show funny.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm laughing the whole time.
If people would have a camera on me and if I'm laying in bed going over the
script,
I mean,
it's all like,
I didn't realize that almost everything they say is funny.
You don't catch that when you're watching,
but that's why the rebrand is so good.
Every time you see new jokes,
but pretty much everything is tied in together.
If every single line you go,
oh my God,
this comes back from that scene before it's,
it's all tied in.
People don't realize what a good standup comedian Kevin is too.
Yeah.
He's a very good writer.
He's a very,
very good writer.
Very funny guy.
Yeah,
a lot of fun.
He just doesn't have enough a standup specials out where people don't appreciate
how good he really is.
He just going to do for the Netflix now.
I'm happy.
Yeah.
I think you already filmed it.
Did you reach out to I think shit,
dude.
I went to a few because once we were there,
he started,
you know,
going to some,
uh,
a standup places,
you know,
to start practicing because she,
it was out for a little bit.
And,
uh,
an album,
we started out together,
we have the same manager and I got him hooked up with my manager back in like
fucking 1993 or some shit.
I don't even remember what year it was when Kevin and I were buddies in New
York.
I remember you,
you used roommates right now.
Windows.
We never lived together,
but we were just like,
we were friends.
We were both like in her early,
early twenties.
We were just starting out.
He told me that he will used to watch the PR Pancras with you.
And that's how he knew me.
And so when I came to America,
I had this management right away calling.
They say,
Hey,
who wants to meet you?
So that was cool.
That is cool.
Yeah.
Kevin used to watch all that shit with me.
We used to watch Pancrase and the early k one fights and everything,
man.
Yeah.
Kevin is a fucking serious martial artists too.
People have no clue that yeah,
he can hit man.
He don't fucking power does a cool thing.
W we're shooting,
here comes the boom.
He at the end with Christoph Sisinsky when you lift,
some are for the arm bar,
right?
So to see this go,
I'm going to bring in into crane with a cable show day because it needs to be
controlled of course,
for the film.
So he's asking,
he says,
oh,
by the way,
can I have your attention?
So all these actual was out there and it says crystal have laid down.
So crystal puts him in an arm bar.
He lifts Christof up above his head,
puts him back for lifts him up above us,
had breaks them back,
does it,
does it three times in a,
he says,
did you see
that?
I just wanted to bring it out there so people get to see,
because now the cable comes in.
Otherwise everybody says that I can't do it.
And everybody was like,
what?
He just did that.
[inaudible] he's a gorilla and his speed and his punches.
If you see him,
that's not sped up.
No,
it on a,
here comes the boom.
I mean the way he's hitting what he's doing,
the very first time I was training him,
I remember coming home and telling my,
if she says,
and I said,
man,
he's a big guy,
but toady listens to every little thing I say and he will do it immediately.
I mean his body,
mind,
body connection is really good and it is reliable.
It had eye coordination as well as good.
Really good goal for two.
Yeah.
He's a good dude.
I've known that guy forever.
All right boss.
Hi.
I think we should wrap this up.
So karate.com if anybody wants to go karate combat,
and you said April 26th,
my yummy in Miami and you could stream it live on karate.com all your free.
Give them your email address.
Boom.
And they hook it up and uh,
it should be fun.
And these guys,
where are the athletes coming from?
All over the world.
That's the greatest thing.
And if you have any,
you know,
contact these people here know,
because they listened to the fans.
So if you,
you say,
hey man,
please don't you think about the low kicks.
I heard it on Joe Rogan,
who we're talking about,
you know,
and maybe watch a few fights and see what you think.
I want you to think,
hey,
yeah,
it should be edit.
Start emailing him,
just talk about it because they throw it into group,
they'll listen to the people.
And then,
uh,
let's see what happen.
Well,
I'm seeing a lot of six pack,
so I'm very impressed already.
They look good boss.
Rutan Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you sir.
Always a pleasure.
My brother.
Godspeed.
Godspeed to you as well.
Bye.
Okay.